there's no time
time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen yeah
it's saturday night yeah
i know i'm already starting to drink a
little bit well what else is new yeah
[Laughter]
my day started off [ __ ] up the first
thing i do is i get up and i [ __ ] sit
down in front of my television i'm at
the foot of the bed on it what do you
call that thing that's it on
i don't know it's just like a little
bench thing like a little yeah it's like
a it's like a box that you it's like
it's like a
well it's it's a bench but you can put
stuff in it put stuff in it yeah got it
at the foot of the beds i sit there you
know what i mean
i'm turning on my xbox and going through
youtube
and [ __ ] have a full cup of coffee
and sit it down
next to me and spill it first thing in
the morning goes down on that thing goes
in
goes inside my [ __ ] pants and
spending an hour cleaning up spilled
coffee
i was pissed i had to get the carpet
shampoo machine
[ __ ] and i i just can't get that smell
of coffee out of my [ __ ]
head and i changed my pants and
everything because you know what i mean
it was sticky you know you had that damn
splenda you know yeah
[ __ ] was sticking you know what i mean
when your pants start to stick at that
so i changed my [ __ ] pants and
everything and it just somehow that
[ __ ] coffee smell just permeated it
that happens sometimes
like when yeah i've had that happen too
like if i had to clean up something
stinky or whatever and it's like it just
kind of stays even though you know it's
not there anymore but it's like you can
still smell it well we better sit on
that bench you know after it dried off
and i think i'm absorbing some
damn coffee molecules i'm gonna start
calling you coffee ass
yeah my ass is drinking coffee by
osmosis
it's like there's another t-shirt
just a picture of tom's ass with a
little
my ass has a conversation with his ass
with his own
some guy he said it good now i'm
sleeping i can't i can't remember
exactly what he said he's probably in
the comments section
but uh is it tom's ass has a
conversation he has a discussion
it was discussion b i remember that
because i because i said next time you
fart i'm going to call it a discussion
that your ass is having with your own
ass
yeah you know what i mean and i did
indeed do that that happened and i never
really quite woke up today i just stayed
sleepy all day
i mean you got all kinds of problems
yeah as i i was coming off that sarbs
cycle
he's always you and you're so hormonal
all my hormones were stabilizing
i was coming off of that male pregnancy
it feels like you're pregnant
i guess it feels like it's you know i
don't know you know i mean
sometimes when a woman tries to describe
to a man what her
cycle is like i think that's i think
it's kind of like what a sarm cycle is
like like you feel boring i guess
it's hard to explain to somebody that
hasn't gone through it
i feel [ __ ] huge which is why i
always went to like
female gynecologists yeah because it's
like you can sit there all day long and
tell a dude like this that and the other
thing and they have no [ __ ] idea what
you're talking about well
sarms aren't androgenic yeah i mean but
they they kind of feel like they are a
little bit
and you get like this swollen water
retention bloating feeling like i hear
women say that
like when they're on a rag so it's like
the man rag
man rag it's like the man rag you
[ __ ] feel bloated and [ __ ]
but well the thing about it is that it's
not just that it's like and the bloating
is usually like
for the first few days and it's not just
like your midsection it's your whole
entire body it's your feet and your
fingers
and everything like yeah because like my
shoes don't fit right and like i can't
get my rings on
and like the same way i was feeling
after about a month of that [ __ ]
everything you feel like the michelin
man pretty much you feel like you're
walking like that like
waddling like you're walking and
sloshing yeah past three days
past three days all of a sudden all this
definition comes back and [ __ ] michael
schaefer said tom is manchester waiting
it's like mastery
exactly masturbating
yeah i'm returning back to normal
for the first like three and a half
weeks it's all right you know i mean you
don't really feel it
but then like those last four or five
days it started to
overwhelm you and you go man i gotta
come off this [ __ ] you feel like
you're a walking fish tank man welcome
to my world
yeah actually welcome to every female of
the world's world
it's like but that that's how we feel
from like age
10 to like age 50. you know what i mean
it's just like a constant [ __ ] roller
coaster
yeah of emotions well you know shitty
feeling
and this is terrible this [ __ ] doesn't
give me any other emotion
other than like towards the end when you
start or
when it starts building up the emotion
is just getting sleepy
yeah sleepy and your brain kind of
malfunctioning
like last week that last show that i did
the last big show
my head was kind of swimming a little
bit i was like yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're trying to rush through it yeah
yeah yeah
i gotta finish this before i go to sleep
you know and and
you feel sleepy and tired but if you lay
down you won't fall asleep you'll just
stay like that
yeah you know like i know that's weird
like kind of sedated well i'm kind of
like always like that because i feel
like i'm always
tired but then i'm always like waking up
in the middle of the night
and then like for whatever reason
because like i have to pee or pookie
jumped on my face or something like that
and then like i'll be like okay i'm
really tired go back to sleep now and
then i'll lay there for like two hours
and i can't go back to sleep it sucks
but yeah
so uh i can't believe it's like we're
[ __ ] five minutes into the show we're
just already talking about like hormones
[Laughter]
oh terrible because i call it irritable
man irritable man syndrome yeah
yeah yeah you do kind of have that a
little bit
[Laughter]
makes you think you got a mangina
[Laughter]
masturbating i like that one i've never
heard that one before that is a good one
did pookie just come in here oh my
goodness she's [ __ ] up cookies made
an early appearance
did you make an early parent what you
doing she's like i heard the show
started she's like i decided i was going
to come you poor little pookie the other
day because she likes to jump up on the
edge of my desk here
and uh i guess she didn't see i guess
like the cord for the mouse was like
over there and i guess she jumped up on
there and didn't see it and she grabbed
that
and so she went and then she went like
flying off back and she knocked
over like the light and the table and
everything and i
i thought she was hurt because i was
like okay oh my god
like show but she ran over there she
knows it's time for the humans to
[ __ ] talk to the lights yeah we're
talking
we're just talking to the lights there's
just lights up here that's all cats
understand
they don't understand what talking
delights is about but they can't stand
it
i know she's like stop talking to the
lights i need to get involved it's like
i really need to jump up here and like
sit on all your buttons and stick my
butthole in your camera which she might
be doing but like i said
i'm just kind of scared because there's
so much stuff like stacked on this side
of the desk
i should probably move all that [ __ ]
just so you can get up here because i
feel bad that
she can't get up here that she fell like
so catastrophically the other day
she didn't get hurt though thankfully i
was like really worried about it because
she just went crash into the [ __ ]
ground
but uh yeah so uh in case you
uh didn't see the little title and
everything like that we are doing a show
today
about the chicago tylenol murders yeah i
remember when this happened
i do as well i was 10 years old um it's
weird because they got the guy on video
it's weird they do yeah yeah or or the
the guy that they think might be it's
like kneeling down loading putting it in
a damn
chair yeah i don't think he was kneeling
exactly but he was just like behind one
of the people that
later died it's been so long so i've
seen it so they thought that it was a
possibility that that's
who it was um but you can't see him real
good all you can see is that he had a
[ __ ] beard or whatever
it's weird to think about and maybe um
you know people that are younger like
because prior to 1982 i don't know if
you guys knew this but you know how like
nowadays you buy like aspirin or
whatever the [ __ ]
and everything is like you know how is
sealed like it has plastic sealant has
foiled
seal and it has all that kind of [ __ ]
okay like before 1982
we'd have any of that [ __ ] no [ __ ] just
opened yeah
you just had to trust that people
weren't going in there
yeah well this changed all that yeah
this was the case
that brought the whole not only like all
the induction seals and all the foil and
all of that kind of stuff
but it also brought in uh the advent of
the caplet
like you know what i mean it's just like
one solid instead of like the caplet
that you can pull apart imagine they're
going to start doing that now with the
[ __ ] ice cream
yeah because everybody's flicking on the
[ __ ] ice cream if you lick on ice
cream you need your [ __ ] ass kicked
well if they catch you yeah you just
need your [ __ ] if they catch you
because
this case also made a product tampering
a federal offense yeah so if somebody
catches you
licking the inside of it that is
considered product tampering and that is
like a biohazard
so i think some of that ice cream
licking was a hoax
i think they licked the ice cream but
then they went and bought the ice cream
but not all of them yeah yeah
why would anybody do something like that
it's just like they're contaminating
[ __ ] food stores
you don't know which one which one you
licks that means you gotta throw it all
out
that's what i mean so it's like i kind
of feel like like i said if they caught
somebody doing that
i imagine they they would prosecute that
as a federal offense because
they just for this reason for this very
reason and they show the dudes that are
doing it the people that are doing you
look at me you know i have a [ __ ] pot
to piss in
so you can't sue them you just gotta
lock them up yeah
you know well yeah cause people like
that should not be running around loose
no you're tampering with the food stores
i mean i know you think it's funny and
everything i'm sure they think it's
funny but that shit's not funny
what if i what they would think that
[ __ ] was real funny if i went to their
house
and grabbed their toothbrush and stuck
that in the crack of my ass
and then just maybe that's what we
should and then make them use
that [ __ ] right back yeah my sweaty
florida
[Laughter]
there you go now you got to use that you
can't buy a new one brush your [ __ ]
teeth
[ __ ]
let the punishment fit the crime yeah
see how funny that [ __ ] is yeah
it's like that's going through your
cupboards [ __ ] grabbing them [ __ ]
oatmeal cookies out of your cups and
rubbing up all my sweaty nuts and [ __ ]
putting them back in there
right eat that [ __ ] that's funny how
[ __ ] funny was that [ __ ]
well see that's the shitty thing about
people like that it's like it's funny
when it's like
somebody else when it's not you because
people like that like have no empathy
because they are like sociopaths
so it's like because to be honest that
would never even occur to me
yeah and like i just it would never
occur to me to do something like
this my good oh my god i can't stand it
that's because that's cause i attacked
your mind
i put that image in your mind them
[ __ ] sweaty ass nuts
there's no hair on them though all
freshly shorn like a gentleman but the
[ __ ] nuts still
on the [ __ ] chocolate chip cookie
yeah sitting up in your cupboard
waiting just waiting for you like a
little time bomb
like a time dog after licking the ice
cream [ __ ]
oh my god you're starting early i know
man
starting earlier i'm waking up but i'm
waking up slowly like
like mothra on [ __ ]
what was the name of that island that
the little [ __ ] giant championship
monster island it wasn't i don't know i
think it was with the little japanese
girls going
yeah whatever it was i don't remember
what they said i had a crush on them
when i was a little kid i said oh yes i
need some little jacks they were pretty
they were pretty funny i need some
little jeffy
yeah you wanted to be a little tiny yeah
yeah
i wanted the little ones yeah i wouldn't
mind having them around
if they could call mothra they were
calling mothra that's what i
mean yeah if they could really come and
they were like three japanese girls too
well you see the japanese knew how to
[ __ ] rip [ __ ] off they saw a tinker
bell and they go yeah we're gonna have
two of them
put two tickets always better two tinker
bells yeah that's what they did
beezness says you need some man ponds
what
some man pods like tampons oh yeah yeah
yeah that's a good one
that is also a good one man
man you guys are [ __ ] here
this show is going to be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show i could already tell
we're over any [ __ ] even though well
yeah like i said even though
you know you guys it's well i guess
because we started because the whole
like ice cream licking thing but that's
like kind of prudent because
you know this is the case where
you know like i said prior to 1982 they
didn't even [ __ ] bother with any of
the
like tamper resistant packaging or any
for anything
um so basically you could just waltz
into any grocery store drugstore or
whatever like open the [ __ ] and do
whatever the
hell you wanted put it back and no one
would be the wiser you know what i'm
saying
so it's like it took somebody killing
seven
people well actually seven people in
that incident and then there were a
bunch of copy
cat crimes because people are the worst
um
you know so it took that happening
before they were like oh maybe
it's not such a good idea to just leave
[ __ ] on shelves that
you can just open and like piss in or
you know
rub your [ __ ] boogery finger in or
whatever is that that's what i mean it's
like when i was a kid man
i always was walking through the balls
you know what i mean this is like when i
was like 10 12 13.
i was walking through those little retro
malls and i'd see them gumball machines
okay and i was go up there and get some
[ __ ] candy out of the gumball
machines right
i saw one time kid was [ __ ]
he was [ __ ] reaching up inside that
damn gumball machine and [ __ ] you
know what i mean putting his
hands in there and pulled it out and he
put all the gumballs and [ __ ] and can't
do the jelly beans
put that [ __ ] in his pocket was eating
some of them like that and i was
watching i was going
man that's [ __ ] gum those just jelly
beans look good i was probably i was a
little kid whenever
you must have been a little probably
like 10 i guess you know it was let's
judge me he's like pretty good little
kid picked his nose after that [ __ ]
oh and i went oh
you still remember it yeah i remember to
this day and i could never get a [ __ ]
any more candy out of those damn
little see don't we always say whenever
we watch the dead mall yeah like who's
been digging it like who's been like
well because a lot of the
dead malls there's nobody in there but
they still have like all those little
like
yeah they can't the gumball machines and
[ __ ] like that like in the middle like
uh
you know concourse yeah like zoom in on
a candy and something that's just color
faded and it's like how long has that
been
how long has it been because it's like
nobody goes in there
and like of the people that go in there
i imagine a tiny tiny tiny percentage
here's something
here's something else you haven't
considered how do they keep the roaches
out of that
um i don't imagine that they do i can
you can't keep
you can't keep a german cockroach out of
[ __ ] you cannot
because they can squish it which tells
me like a piece of paper every now and
then roach is getting them things
then you you eat oh i'm sure it's more
than every now and then well that's why
i don't go in there and get
well i don't really like gumballs anyway
so it's just kind of like kind of lucky
in that regard
i don't want anything that's like
[ __ ] loose like that god damn
i know i wanted a [ __ ] package i'm
not a savage
so they're in there [ __ ] saying they
can't get the
image of my balls
still thinking about my testicles it's
all right too
in a pass gonna pass she's gonna have
nightmares about your testicles now
yeah i wonder what color they are
wondering what color is this yeah just
yeah
their move what color is that
it's like a lavender-y purpley kind of
color i don't think they're that color
they're chartreuse
i'm making [ __ ] up i know
i know this is this is terrible like i
said we're talking about we gotta get we
gotta we're talking about a [ __ ]
tragic case right here guys
first we gotta stop we're so
disrespectful gotta stop that
bizarre says like michael jackson's
balls tom's has glitter on them
man stop making [ __ ] up of my balls man
man's getting ready you brought it up
very protective about it you brought it
up
it was just in the heat of the moment
man i was thinking chocolate chip
cookies and how would i sabotage
somebody's chocolate chip cookies i
don't need to explain myself i don't
need to explain
my thought process i say whatever comes
out of my mouth you do
just say whatever comes out of my mouth
zach says what i'm amazed by is how the
gum
was the same flavor but the color made
your mind trick you into thinking of
something else yeah
yeah i think you're right that's crazy
well because
i mean the way something looks and the
way something smells like goes a long
way to like
kind of tricking your brain yeah like
changing the ones that would tempt me
though was
like the mike and ikes you know what i
mean yeah things were like
mike and ike's in the damn machine right
right yeah i don't think it said mike
and ike on them maybe it did they were
like the off-brand
plenty right and i'm looking at those
things and i like
i love those candies but i'm looking at
them in those machines every time i pass
by look at those and their color is
always off
like they've been sun bleached yeah
because they've been in there they've
been there forever
five years yeah for ten years or however
long that mall's been dead actually
like in the center is there like a
[ __ ] ants nest in the center of them
or a [ __ ] nest of roaches in the
middle living in them you know just
that's quite an image yeah i'm not that
bothered because i
don't i don't ever eat anything out of
those because i'm not a dummy
another one used to bother me when i was
living in mississippi was you could go
to the little dime stores
and up on the counter there was a two
big old jars one of them had pickled
eggs
yeah i had pickled pig's feet yeah we
had a 7-eleven next door my grandma's
house had that
you'd look down at the bottom of the
pig's feet one man and you're thinking
how long ago did that pig die
[Laughter]
but they're pickled so it's they're
pickled but you know you're thinking
like
that that i'm not gonna eat that either
should be dead and long gone and rotten
and you're gonna eat that foot it was a
foot it's a trotter
yeah that's the classy word for it the
trotter because they trot around
which doesn't sound much better no
they're trotting around like pig [ __ ]
in them yeah trotter sounds grosser to
me than your feet
yeah my dad used to eat the [ __ ] out of
him yeah my grandma they're just [ __ ]
bone though that's
all that's old southerners that's cool
southern [ __ ]
like i said i'm putting your damn
peanuts in coca-cola and stuff
yeah that's peanuts and pepsi yeah the
salt and all
right and as my dad was doing i said
well you do that for us you student i
was a kid
i said why are you doing it now because
i used dude when i was kid
that's the only answer you need why'd
you do it back then because it was cheap
it's like all right just because it was
there it was like like you just eat
anything that was like
whether it was like yeah stinky gumballs
and like some malt
or whether it was just like some random
like if you found a sandwich like just
sitting on the side of the road
go pick it up and eat it because there
it is you go to work
you go you go to wards and you you go to
wards and you get that [ __ ]
sausage biscuit that sausage biscuit
sandwich and you put the grape jelly
and the hot sauce on it and the tabasco
on it because it's free because it's
free because it's free
you used to do that waffle house when
you used to get a waffle house now she
asked her i do this is because it's free
because it's free
yeah because they had the hot sauce and
the jelly and everything right there
he's like you might as well just like
take advantage put it on
but i let you have some of it it's good
well i'm not a big fan of hot sauce well
actually
my stomach is not a real big fan of hot
sauce let's say that
i put grape jelly on anything yeah
i get that i grab jelly on anything yeah
grape jelly is good grape jelly on
meatloaf
yeah apricot jelly on meatloaf yeah i
like it sometimes
yeah like a lot of times i just like
we're gonna eat meatloaf like the one
you made the other day it was good with
just ketchup on it
yeah um but it was good with the apricot
jelly on it too or the jam or whatever
it's a southern thing yeah we like sweet
meat
yeah that's another thing it might be a
black thing too
it might be the same thing it probably
is because i do feel like we stole a lot
of our food from the africa they showed
us how to do it
they did yeah because we didn't know
what the [ __ ] we were doing
no it's just so they were just kind of
we were kind of like oh we're going to
steal y'all's food because it's way
better
all that [ __ ] came from back in the day
and you know
white people white people didn't deep
fried that's an african invention
yeah and when you start deep frying food
that opens up a whole new [ __ ]
possibility it really does because deep
fried chicken and deep fried
yeah deep frying [ __ ] country steak
you're [ __ ] pounding the steaks out
deep frying it
frying okra try to boil okra it just
turns into slime yeah
yeah you [ __ ] deep fry it then it's
delicious
[ __ ] right everything deep fried is
delicious
yeah it's not good for you anymore but
that's okay
at least it tastes good that's revenge
on us
they killed us with [ __ ] diabetes and
damn
see they're playing the long game and
the indians showed us how to smoke
that's
vengeance again long game yeah they were
playing the long game i see what you did
there
carbohydrates back yeah
[Laughter]
all right gotta get back to the show so
we gonna actually talk about
like some murders okay yeah the show was
over did you have any shout outs
i did that's what i was just gonna say i
actually do have a couple of shout outs
um we have a new patron this week james
h
so hey uh thank you for coming along and
being our patron
uh we always could use more patrons so
you know you you told me that you had to
do more patron plugs
yeah that's right so don't forget that's
your job
tina said hot sauce on popcorn is great
i've heard that
yeah it might be good i've heard that um
yeah you can put pretty much anything on
popcorn like any kind of like spice mix
or anything like that yeah what about
curry powder
i think tea would taste like yeah tina's
tina's black she's saying
deep fried pickles oh deep fried pickles
are the [ __ ]
best what's funny what's funny tila is
that cranberry sauce
is popular in the south also it's
popular with
you know like i said in the south
southern food is black people food we we
all eat same thing basically
people from north would freak out over
the [ __ ] that we would eat
but uh cranberry sauce actually that's
not southern and that's not african
that's british i think the british were
into that
right i um i can't remember actually i
thought that was a british thing
although cranberries grow in like bogs
yeah you know so i'm not really i'm not
like i'm wearing that totally wrong but
i thought that was like one of
one of the few like uh european things
that they had had berries
maybe it could be i'm not real sure i
was pretty good with
my culinary history i thought cranberry
yeah you could be right
i think it's british i just can't
remember i don't think it's american but
i might be wrong i think i think it was
transplanted here yeah see michael
shafer's deep-fried broccoli
oh yeah bees nest collard greens with uh
bacon grease
yeah everything is better with the
addition of beef i think i think what's
funny is i think deep frying
actually in japan they call that tempura
they'll batter it and deep fry it i
don't think that's native to japan i
think that's also
i think they got that from us and
yeah now i'm gonna have to look up the
history remember if i remember correctly
i'm fascinated by food history we should
do a whole [ __ ] show well i guess we
kind of
i could be wrong but i think i remember
that they got it from us which would
mean southerners which would be
africans yeah because they gave it to us
so that's funny how a good idea can
travel across the [ __ ] world
maria said cranberries grow in north
american bogs
boosts are produced in wisconsin all
right
i must be wrong right now check on
tempura form because
because cranberry is like such an
integral and integral part of
thanksgiving that i figured it must be
like a like an american thing
because most of the food that's
thanksgiving adjacent
like turkeys and corn and all that kind
of stuff is kind of like
north south central american yeah stuff
yeah check on tempura for me people i
think tempura
is uh african by way of america i think
yeah i think it is oracle says all these
shows end up being about food they do
yeah i know
i don't know we said it's like you'd
think that we just like sit around
eating all the time we don't
but it's like but i guess that's kind of
why because we're like man i wish i
could eat all these things
except i'd weigh 400 pounds but it's
like so we just have to like talk about
it
yeah man badgers in there talking about
[ __ ] curry popcorn
see that's what i said i feel like that
would be good like curry powder like on
popcorn would probably be really good
i think i'd have to add some sugar to
that make that like a sweet curry though
i don't know i just have to try
i have to see i've had like i've had
like um twice fried like french fries
with like curry ketchup on them and that
was [ __ ] delicious
yeah i've never had a curry cake and
curry
curried mayonnaise they put curry and
mayonnaise and stuff like that yeah
that's good
um but yeah so oh and it was hungry i
know
tempura originated with the portuguese
oh okay
the thing is though is i bet you the
portuguese got that from africans
maybe there was a lot of trade right uh
the uh the the portuguese were an
offshoot of the spanish and
the spanish empire had access to africa
and
they and you know what i mean they had
they also had um
access to uh central and south america
you know people forget you know we're
we're kind of like
products of the [ __ ] british empire
me and jenny so
we see things from the from the from the
perspective of the english-speaking
world
spain kicked ass too they had a huge
empire they were everywhere they did
yeah
so i i guarantee you deep frying
the spaniards got that from [ __ ]
africa they didn't come up with that
that
deep frying is not a european thing
yeah i don't think it is actually i mean
like i said it's
you know as with anything like culinary
it's like i'm sure
somebody like somewhere like thought of
it like in other parts of the world but
whether it's
like spread and everything portuguese
saw that they saw that or they had black
cooks that made it
to them they may have had african cooks
that made that for them and they
and that's where the idea came from the
date of the generation this is the most
delicious thing ever
which it is almost every almost all my
studies
of culinary history you trace deep
frying back to africa that's how
and it was common in africa deep fat
frying you guys can look it up
i don't think there was that just didn't
happen in europe until
contact with africa yeah
it must been late because they were
african there was contact with africa
with ancient rome and
romans don't ever mention deep frying so
i guess the africans figured that out
kind of around the same time they taught
us how to do it
it must not have been that for which the
world should be eternally grateful
yeah yeah because deep frying do you try
anything again
everything better it makes everything
everything is better it's a good idea it
makes everything less healthy but it
makes everything
taste better i don't care what it is
well you're cooking you're rendering
meat
yeah all right and the fat that comes
off that meat there's no reason to throw
that away
well yeah it's a waste so you just save
it and then you just keep reheating it
and you cook stuff in there
and then you come up with all the weird
things you can put on the meat
when you cook it in that hot oil and
then you're getting nutrition from it
instead of just throwing it away so
you're making that animal last longer so
it's practical
yeah then it's just a good idea and it
just tastes good
yeah and then you get some crazy white
[ __ ] want to cook you cook the
[ __ ] in motor oil like i told you that
we're gonna move on and then we start
like now we start like every
thanksgiving you always got some people
like cooking an entire turkey
yeah like deep frying which which i've
heard is delicious i haven't done it
actually you have a chip you have a duck
inside a chicken or chicken inside of a
duck inside of a turkey a traduca yeah
it's a turducken
turducken turducken yeah i've never i've
never tried a turducken we're
this is becoming a food show we can't we
should do like i said we should just do
a whole show on food we're probably an
hour into the show though
uh no we're just at their well actually
i was gonna say 37 minutes but it's
actually just 27 minutes because 10
minutes of it was like the starting soon
thing um also i want to say if you
are a patron and you haven't voted in
the poll yet
for the movie retrospective we're gonna
do the day before halloween
and the topic we're gonna do for the
halloween special then get over there
and vote on that stuff
although the topic it looks like one of
them is like the clear forerunner i mean
you have until tomorrow at noon uh
eastern standard time to vote
but it looks like one thing is gonna win
and
so so i'm already like kind of so i'm
not sure what movie's gonna win yet
because there's a couple that are kind
of like close
also because halloween week is coming up
and i'm very very excited about it
so like starting tomorrow uh all the
matinee shows
are gonna be newer halloween themed
movies so we've already watched a couple
we're going to review
one tomorrow we're going to review on
monday tuesday wednesday and then
the witching hour show on thursday is
going to be kind of like
halloween related and then we'll see
whatever the
movie retrospective comes up as because
that's going to be like the voted thing
but the ones that i put in the poll are
like all
halloween related movies so let's talk
about
the chicago title in all murders now as
i said
uh this happened in 1982 and prior to
1982
there was actually no regulation no rule
no you know no anything that said that
if if you had a drug
food packaging anything that you had to
have it so people couldn't [ __ ] with it
like there was no such thing really as
like tamper resistant packaging well
there wasn't a problem people had
respect for [ __ ] usually
yeah yeah although i feel like i don't
know maybe maybe should happen but like
it did it wasn't widespread enough or i
don't know what it was when i was a kid
the only thing that i noticed
unusual about packaging is that some
things like medicine were child proof
lids yeah like you had to like push them
down and then like yeah i couldn't get
them open i was trying to get into the
down flinstone
yeah cause they're because you're right
i'm gonna od on
flintstones kid remember those yeah
it's [ __ ] why would you want to eat
all of them they tasted they tasted
[ __ ] good i love it
when i was a little kid you know i mean
i was like no i want the fred flintstone
they tasted kind of you know what they
the smell of them
the smell of them reminded me of you
remember that i don't know if they still
make it but that tetramine fish food
no they did not taste like that oh no
they smelled like that they smelled
taste like sweet tarts with less sugar i
don't like sweet tarts i love them they
were kind of sour
yeah i got into the mexican cabinets i'm
going to eat all these plants total
vitamins what would happen to you if you
ate a whole bottle of flintstone
vitamins
probably not stomach yeah you might get
you might get kind of sick but yeah i
don't think it would work
no i'm gonna look that up after the show
what would happen if you ate a hole
that was bad i'd climb it on top of the
damn refrigerator trying to eat my mom's
diet chocolates and [ __ ]
remember those things they called them
aids they were called aids yeah they're
a-y-d-s yeah yeah they look a little
square chocolate thanks
they're [ __ ] terrible man i mean
they're trying to eat a bunch of them
and [ __ ]
wait wait okay so they were so feel like
a diet aid were they laxatives
no they were i think they were kind of
like a little protein
bar okay i think and there's just be
like an appetizer
there were some laxatives that were like
chocolate right though yeah but that it
wasn't that yeah that was actually
because it wasn't
there you go because i feel like there
was a lot of like there was a lot of
people would joke and they'd be like
switch out your chocolate with excellent
like make you poop yourself real chewy
and they didn't have a good
the flavor of a shitty but they look
like chocolate and i'd get up there and
try to eat the whole [ __ ] box up
and get unsatisfied and then i'd [ __ ]
open get the sugar but get the sugar jar
and [ __ ]
take a couple teaspoons of sugar and
just eat that
and then i found the sugar numbers that
you put on top of birthday cakes and
they put up a birthday cake had like a
one and a half yeah yeah they're like
three inch tall numbers
yeah trying to eat those they do look
delicious yeah they were
waxed they were terrible but i got about
halfway through it
it didn't make any sense for your boy
boys don't make these this isn't that
good
try that yeah that's not too good
he's good but i feel like we try to eat
candles
what's up well i can get i get that
because candles do actually and
especially like
they made a lot of candles and they
smell nice too
so you know they look like you're
getting like should be good but it's not
they don't really taste like much of
anything unless they're scented and then
they taste kind of chemically and it's
not like we were starving or hungry or
anything just this little boy's about
like a dog or a monkey
yeah so you get to a certain age i know
i have brothers but well that's the
thing it's like it's
it's just funny to me because now the
whole time you were saying that i had
this like mental image of like little
baby tom
yeah and he's just like climbing all
over the kitchen all over everything
just eating everything that wasn't
nailed
yeah yeah and he's eating [ __ ] you're
not supposed to eat
eating [ __ ] nut birthday cake numbers
and [ __ ] he's like here's a glass vase
what does this taste like
you can't even everybody's like having
your mom had to like hide all the [ __ ]
i'm sure there's a lot of i'm sure
there's a lot of guys in here that know
what i'm talking about i mean looking
they're probably doing the same thing
little boy's just eating everything yeah
ah
yeah they were eating elementary school
paste yep eat that
well yeah a lot of people ate that
because it smelled it's because of the
smell yeah
i never ate it but i knew a couple kids
that did yeah
i was always more fascinated like the
paste was neat but i i was always kind
of
kind of more fascinated with the rubber
cement which smelled awful but also
smelled kind of good
i liked that it was kind of like i was
like oh it's like snot
you know what i mean i never ate it
though i didn't want to eat it all right
so
like i said so prior to 1982 for all of
you
children out there there was no such
thing as really tampers into packaging
because i guess everyone was just kind
of like oh i suppose so it's like they
would just eat food
even if somebody licked it or put poison
in it as they did in this case
and they didn't really think about it
anymore but this kind of [ __ ] this
changed all that this um basically
brought in the whole new thing like i
said this was the invention of the
caplet
instead of like the capsule that could
be pulled apart uh this was like the
uh the advent of the all the tamper
resistant packaging the foil
and the induction seals the foils all
that kind of stuff
um and also it's kind of interesting
because
um oh and it's also this was also the
start of
product tampering being a federal
offense whereas prior to that it was
just kind of like a minor
i don't even know if it was a [ __ ]
law before that because they thought no
nobody would [ __ ] do it wasn't a
popular thing to do yeah it's like
obviously so nobody like thought to make
a law about it
so let's go uh back in time we'll talk a
little bit of a timeline
as to what happened and like i said this
is a [ __ ] terrible like seven people
died
okay like in this one and like i said
there was some copycat [ __ ] later
um where more people died so we'll talk
about that a little bit too
so september 29th 1982
there is a 12 year old girl named mary
kellerman
and she's from schaumburg illinois and
she wakes up and she's not feeling so
good um so
her parents are like okay well you stay
home from school
and she takes either one or two tylenol
i'm imagining it was probably just
one because i think the kids 12 and
under they usually tell you to take one
and then 12 whenever they tell you to
take two so i don't know that's the
thing
so she takes one or two tylenol and then
her dad says like she goes back to bed
and then her dad said
i heard her like go into the bathroom
and then like you know heard the door
closed or the door lock whatever
um or the door didn't lock whatever and
then she's like and then he's like and
then i heard something like
dropping or falling so he's like so i go
and like knock on the bathroom door and
i'm just like hey are you okay in there
and i didn't get any answer
and then finally he goes and opens the
bathroom door and his daughter is just
laying there on the floor like
unconscious like in her pajamas
so she gets rushed to the hospital
but she is pronounced dead at 10 a.m
she had taken the pills at i believe a
little bit before 7am
so she dies now a couple hours later
this is the same day
um at noon there's this guy named adam
janus
and he was uh 27 years old he was a
postal worker in arlington heights which
was another like suburb of chicago
um he also didn't feel very good that
day he thought he was like maybe getting
a cold or whatever so he called in sick
to work
now he goes to pick up his kids from
preschool at lunchtime
and while he was like out and about he
stopped at a drugstore and got some
tylenol
he came home he ate lunch with his kids
then he said i'm gonna take a couple
tylenol and i'm gonna lay down because i
don't feel all that good
so he takes the pills he goes to lay
down and then a couple minutes later he
comes
like like out of the kitchen like he's
obviously in a lot of distress and he
just collapses
so he gets rushed to the hospital 3 15
p.m
he's pronounced dead only about three
hours later
now the doctor at first um he wasn't
entirely sure what it was
uh at first he was kind of like made
cardiac arrest but he wasn't real
you know he wasn't real certain about
that diagnosis
and he's like so adam's whole family was
there he had a wife named teresa um
adam's parents were at the hospital and
a whole bunch of other people like his
brother and all this other stuff
so after adam janus was pronounced dead
this whole his whole family like went
back to his house
so i'm presuming presuming they're going
back they're like you know
plan the funeral to mourn or whatever it
is that they're doing so they all go
back to his house what are you smirking
at i'm laughing what tila said
what'd she say she said she'd take a
peppermint stick and stick it into a
damn pickle and [ __ ]
suck the juice out to the pickle through
through the peppermint stick i was
laughing because
that just sounds nasty as [ __ ] but i
used to do the same thing
you said but i started off doing it with
lemons yeah
yeah lemon and peppermint sounds pretty
yeah that was really good that was
really good but
i i heard of the pickle thing and i
tried it
it wasn't as good well it's like i can
see how like it sounds gross at first
blush but then like sweet and sour is
kind of like
yeah sometimes that can work tila you're
not the originator of the pickle
how that would happen is you're supposed
to do it with a lemon
you could do it with an orange too but
you're supposed to do a little lemon but
you run out of lemons and everybody
back in the day had those [ __ ]
pickles in a pickle jar yeah
so there's only a matter of time for
somebody tried that it kind of works but
it's not it
lemon's much better beezness says
remember jolly ranchers in zima
i remember that i remember i remember do
you remember when zema was like a big
huge
remember when that was the 90s right
yeah it was early 90s i want to say yeah
because it was right after i graduated
liquor that tasted like sprite it was
good but they charged too much for it
and the [ __ ] was effeminate as [ __ ]
well it's kind of it's just it's just a
trendy thing just like kind of like
white claw is now
yeah if your buddies saw you drinking
zima at the [ __ ] bar they [ __ ]
you'd never live it down
you know i mean it's like it's like
you've been caught flipped gay or
something
oh you flipped gay on us drinking zima
huh
you know it's like i told you that the
kids in the hall did a whole
sketch um yeah about the girl drink
drunk
yeah yeah and he was just like a drop on
a girl drinking yeah and like really
girl drinks like in the [ __ ] with the
umbrellas sticking out of the [ __ ] and
everything and he's just like laying
around the bargain
[Music]
zima was the advertising campaign yeah
in a white suit and he's trying to be
sophisticated
and they had the wrong spokesman to sell
zima
to men you know i'm talking about
instead it sold it
to kind of like girls and college age
pseudo-intellectuals that's well the
thing about it though is that
dudes were already a pretty solid like
alcohol market
so i feel like they were trying to
expand into like to get more women to
drink
to get more like other types of people
to drink that doesn't do you know what i
mean
no i'm just saying that that's kind of
like the marketing that they they should
have had zima the [ __ ] spokesman
should have been a damn pro wrestler
you should be snatched smack a [ __ ]
upside the head
drop your balls on a [ __ ] zima
that's what it should have been and they
just thought a lot of it and it
shouldn't have had a sophisticated
packaging
you know man it should have just been
like a fists
fists coming at you with a penis
underneath it like a dick a [ __ ]
crooked crooked it's got to be crooked
not straight it's a crooked
coming at you gnarly nasty and crooked
and with the fists that's what it should
have been do you guys remember this was
probably very short-lived but i think
this was
god this must have been like early 2000s
late 90s early 2000s
there was i don't think it was alcoholic
i think it was bottled water
some kind of i knew that i knew it was
gonna laugh at that [ __ ]
or it was some or it was some kind of uh
or it was some kind of like flavored
bottled water or something and it came
in this really nice
like blue bottle and it had like
it had like uh it was ribbed for her
pleasure let's say that
or it kind of looked like it had like
little speckles on it and the bottled
water was called
balls yes b-a-l-l-z
does anybody remember that because i
used to work with a guy who would bring
it into work all the time
everybody's talking about and i thought
the bottle was really nice
actually it was a nice looking bottle
it's called pop rocks skittles
yeah you guys need to get all right stop
the [ __ ] food talk
this is going to become a food show we
got to get back to the [ __ ] crime
you're the you're the one that keeps i
know it goes sideways she'll go south
it's my fault people did i'm gonna take
responsibility orbits i remember balls i
did not
maybe it was regional because he was the
only person that i saw that had it he
used to like bring it into work as i
and he kept the bottles because he
thought they were funny so he had like
on the shelf like above his
computer there was like a whole bunch of
these blue bottles that said balls on
them
and like i said they were like they were
like textured the bottles they had like
little like dimpled like a golf ball
except opposite so okay so
adam janice has died his whole family is
at the uh
hospital and when he is pronounced dead
they all go back to his house in
arlington heights
now the same day half an hour after adam
janus is pronounced dead
this is at 3 45 pm there's this other
woman and her name is mary reiner she's
27 years old
um she lives in winfield another suburb
of chicago
now she um was hadn't been feeling all
that good she had just given birth to
her fourth
child i believe it was only a week or
two prior
um so same kind of thing she wasn't
feeling good she took a couple of
tylenol and almost
immediately collapsed
now again same day five o'clock in the
evening
uh the janice family you know who all
the relatives of adam janus who had died
earlier in the afternoon
they're all at his house and they're
like you know mourning
planning the funeral whatever it is that
you do after somebody that young like
dies
of what they at the time thought was
cardiac arrest
now adam had a younger brother named
stanley
and stanley had uh chronic back pain
so he says to his wife
now hit it's as confusing because
stanley and adam
they their wives were both named theresa
like one
with an h and one without an h so that's
confusing
so he says to his wife teresa hey go get
me some tylenol or go see if
adam's got any tylenol because he was
having some back pain
so stanley takes two tylenol and then
she gives him two and then she took to
herself because i guess she wasn't
feeling all that good
and then minutes later he collapses to
the ground
and then a couple minutes after that she
collapses to the ground so they started
having
like the same uh symptoms
now this is okay so this is crazy the
doctor that works at the hospital where
they take it his name is dr kim
and he's like i was getting ready to
leave the hospital it was like 5 30 and
it was like the end of a shift
then the nurse comes in and says hey um
they're bringing the janus family back
like you know the relatives of the
person that died here earlier
and he said oh well is it the guy's
parents you know because they were older
and it's like he assumed that they had
had some kind of like stress related
whatever because of the death
and the nurse says no it's the brother
who was younger
he was like only 25 i believe and
he's like so the doctor's like what the
[ __ ] he's like i was just talking to
this guy earlier and he was like super
healthy he was just like this big buff
healthy dude
and um he's like well what happened to
him and they said they're doing cpr on
him it looks like he had a cardiac
arrest as well
and he's like an oh the same [ __ ] also
happened to the wife
so at this stage okay so there's like a
nurse and she's like
um working at the same hospital she's
like so they're bringing in all these
people from the same house so that
raises red flags because obviously when
the 12 the first girl that died the 12
year old girl mary kellerman
um that was weird but they didn't really
there was no pattern there was no reason
it's like she just kind of healed it's
there there's no reason to think that
there was that she had been poisoned or
anything like that like you know what i
mean
it's for something like that you have to
have like a pattern established
unfortunately
so they didn't really and by the time
she got to the hospital
i mean they wouldn't have been able to
do anything anyway
but at this stage since it was like
three people from the same household now
they're like okay well obviously
something
weird is going on so they're like we
need like a public health representative
we need to figure out
what it is it has to be something in the
environment that's causing this
so basically what they do they're like
we go to the hat they go back to the
janice house because they said it's got
to be something here that's causing it
so while that's going on so they all
decide they go they all like get the
doctor they get the nurse they get
everything and they go back to the house
and start like searching everything to
look for anything in the environment
that could cause the symptoms that
they're
seeing meanwhile in another part of
illinois lombard yet another i think
that's another suburb of chicago
this was 6 30 p.m there was another
woman
named mary mcfarland she was uh 31
she's at work um and she tells people
hey i have a headache
she goes into the back takes a tylenol
one or two they don't really know how
many and then minutes later
she also collapses to the floor now
they kind of suspected like her
co-workers were kind of like well she
must have
like did she eat something bad or
something like that because they
couldn't figure out anything else
so that's going on 8 p.m
they get like all the investigators the
public health officials like the doctors
and nurses they show up at
the janus house and start uh going
through the place
so they're kind of like the investigator
gets there he's like
he's like i don't know why i thought
this but it's like i thought that we
were just gonna like walk into the house
and be like oh
obviously like that's what it caught
what's causing it but it's like
obviously that's not what happened
so they start looking around now
the nurse nurse jensen she's apparently
kind of
i mean according to her and according
some other people she was kind of the
only one that was on the ball
so she goes in the bathroom and starts
going through all their [ __ ] [ __ ] in
their medicine cabinets
and she's like now there's nothing weird
in there it was just like regular
over-the-counter medications couple
prescription medications nothing
alarming or anything like that
but um you know so she's like but it's
got to be something in here now one of
the investigators did go down to the
basement
and they said that there was some metal
working equipment
in the basement now in metal working
i guess sometimes they use cyanide for
polishing metal
so that did kind of like bring some
alarm bells because i guess some of the
doctors and nurses did say you know
did kind of come across like cyanide
poisoning like how quickly it came
on and everything like that so like
maybe that's maybe that's what it was
but it's like they couldn't see how like
anybody had been contaminated from it
it's used in old-school gun blueing
process
yeah yeah yeah it's used in a lot of
industrial applications which a lot of
people don't know
how toxic old-school metal work was
i mean some of the new ships they have
out for guns like [ __ ]
nitride and [ __ ] cerakote that [ __ ]
is so good compared to what they used to
have back then man dealing with
that [ __ ] blue horse hooves and
cyanide
man that [ __ ] was [ __ ] caustic same
thing with all that chrome plating
that was also caustic this dude does
sound like he has
access to metal working uh material
it's possible possible i'm not really
sure possible
i mean but but there's just a way to get
it but they're just saying that
um they found a couple things like that
like in the basement of the
house of the guy that had died and like
where two of his family members
subsequently died and they were just
kind of like oh maybe that had something
to do with it however
at the same time that the nurse was
going through all the
drugs and [ __ ] in the bathroom she
happened to open up the tylenol
container and she's like you know back
then obviously they didn't have any like
[ __ ]
there was no seal it was just cotton in
there and she dumped a bunch of mountain
counted
the um the capsules and she's like okay
well there are six capsules missing
and there are three people dead two
capsules each so she's like maybe that's
what it is so she's like so i'm gonna
take this with me
just in case so she decides to take it
so like i said good for her because she
was like
[ __ ] on the ball so
while they're uh at the house looking
through the [ __ ] stanley janus the
brother of adam janus who died earlier
uh at 8 15 stanley janus is pronounced
dead
meanwhile in another part of town 9
30 p.m there's a woman named paula
prince she's 35
years old and she's a flight attendant
with united airlines
now she has just come in she's landed at
o'hare
she was coming from las vegas on a
flight and uh she's had kind of a long
day
she feels kind of shitty she stops at a
walgreens on north wells street and buys
some tylenol 10 p.m
they are kind of like they they get back
to the hospital like all the
investigators and the doctor and the
nurse and everything they get back and
they do a meeting and they're like okay
like what the [ __ ] did we find at this
people's house so nurse jensen she puts
the tylenol bottle on the table she says
i think it's this
she's like there were six pills missing
three people are dead
we can't find anything else in the house
like the metal working stuff
was suspicious but it's like they there
was really no way there didn't seem to
be anything down there that would have
like accounted for
like three people in the same family
dying on the same day so she's kind of
like i think it's this
so she said at first nobody believed her
they're like it's tylenol people take
tylenol all the time it's fine
nothing i mean nobody thought that
someone would
have adulterated it i guess it was just
something that didn't occur to them
so they were just kind of like no
there's just no way i still think the
metal working stuff is a good clue i
think whoever poisoned him did have
access to that kind of stuff
maybe that's the easiest way to get uh
cyanide if you're in metal working yeah
big jim used to have it remember tell
you about big jim um
i've told stories about big jam yeah i
don't remember that my granddad kind of
raised him a little bit he was a
machinist
he worked for the cops and stuff and he
had all kinds of [ __ ] like that in his
damn metal shop
he could just he could build a gun up
from just build it from the ground up
out of nothing
by hand yeah he'd just make it an
absolute replica of a night of a cult
1911 45 to make it all by hand
yeah [ __ ] yeah he was he was
fantastic but uh
he had all that [ __ ] i saw him one time
take an eye dropper
of some kind of a sulfuric acid
and drop it on another guy's hand to
burn a wart off of it
and he knew exactly how much of that
[ __ ] to [ __ ] drop through a damn
syringe
and it fell on top of this nasty ass
wart and he was gritting his teeth and
it was smoking and popping and it ate
that ward off
leaving a small rounded pock mark the
only thing that was left on that damn
finger i was i was [ __ ] amazed
that's crazy yeah he knew exactly how
much to drop on her that was a dude that
would drink the [ __ ] um
um hydrogen peroxide oh that guy yeah
you same one he had all the [ __ ]
chemicals and [ __ ]
well like i said hydrogen and peroxide
they do tell you you can like use it as
mouthwash but i've never heard of
anybody
drink it you drop it into this or
dropping it in your ear
drop it in your distilled water at a
certain dosage and drink it
and uh he said that it had it it
helped the oxygen that oxygen it helped
to oxygenate your blood
that it made transmission of oxygen into
the red blood cells easier that was his
theory
yeah i don't think that's out he lived a
long time though man and he died but
that could be like
lots of things yeah you don't have a
control sample so there's no way of
never
he just theorized it i guess he knew
about chemistry you know
he said he'd feel better so he'd drink
some of that
and uh crazy [ __ ] mississippi
machinist guy
died in his sleep in his 80s must be
nice yeah just died asleep didn't wake
up
yeah gym you knew my granddad
big gym so he let me come in the shop
all the time [ __ ] around
michael schaefer said good thing it
wasn't a penis wart
yeah i don't know if anybody'd like one
no what the penis work i don't think
anybody would like
on the outside of his index finger right
here and he [ __ ] dropped it on there
and that sucker he's holding it
like that and i'm watching it and he's
got his hands [ __ ] on that disc
and it's going i can hear it popping
and it's smoke coming out of it and
everything he goes and jim would be like
that should have been the perfect amount
it'll eat that down and you'll see there
it goes it's gone
all right all right that's it that's it
you've been like that you're good
yeah yeah see sheila said my dad gargled
with it baking soda toothpaste yeah yeah
yeah
that's like they do tell you you can
gargle with it it's supposed to be good
for your
mouth but i didn't i never heard of
anybody like he drank hydrogen peroxide
out of distilled water it was a special
kind of hydrogen peroxide too it wasn't
it wasn't like what you got from the um
uh from from from the grocery store it
was stuff you got from a chemical
plant yeah it was a lot more
concentrated because i think it's mostly
water in water
when you buy it you know you know if you
buy it at the [ __ ]
pharmacy yeah i think it's mostly water
this was the real
[ __ ] it came well yeah i mean the
peroxide you buy at the grocery store
99 water yeah this was the pure [ __ ]
he said it would [ __ ] put a lot of
pep in your step
so it had some kind of effect on it
victor said in the early days of the hiv
pandemic they would drink peroxide to
oxygenate the blood and kill the virus
it didn't work it didn't work yeah no i
i imagine it didn't work
don't don't drink [ __ ] that's just
somebody on youtube told you to drink
seriously
i mean i won't have to tell you guys
that but from my
opinion from my observation jim had a
reaction to it
now looking back on it you know i was
kind of a kid you know
i was i was even before i was in the
army so i must have been about 17 18
19 probably 18 19 when this was going on
he he said it gave you more energy so i
was were you getting kind of high off of
it maybe or
was that just like a placebo effect i
don't know
you don't really have no way of telling
because a lot of drugs work because of
like a placebo effect because you're
like oh i took something
so it will make me feel better or you
know what i mean
because a lot of it a lot of it is like
what your perception is of how
he swore by it well yeah but
anecdotes are not data yeah that's the
first thing they teach you in any
critical thinking class
well maybe one of the first things they
teach you he loved [ __ ] conspiracy
theories too
he loved that well see that's that makes
me even more suspicious he was
pre-internet conspiracy theories
he told me all kinds of wild [ __ ] well
yeah they had conspiracy theories
they go all over the internet now
they're just like much easier to
disseminate
unfortunately that's a whole other show
in itself the [ __ ] big gyms
conspiracy theories
[Laughter]
that just you know what i just thought
of like a really cool shirt design it
looked like a like an old-fashioned you
know like those old-timey like victorian
like snake oil like the labels like you
know what i mean
i could have one that looks like that
but it says like being [ __ ] conspiracy
theory [ __ ] whatever
although man i tell you what man some of
his [ __ ] was kind of true
he's talking about you know like the uh
he was big into that
federal reserve act he was saying yeah
they passed it on christmas you know
what i mean to try to get through the
senate and everything i thought that was
[ __ ] turns out that part was true
he was talking about big banking cartels
and
the the federal reserve bank and he knew
about all this [ __ ]
going back to the 50s you know 50s 60s
70s
you know so he he kind of grew up with
all that [ __ ] but uh
some of that [ __ ] that he said was true
but you know
hey man call [ __ ] a conspiracy fine
big jim's conspiracy juice yeah
i'm seeing it i'm seeing a [ __ ] shirt
right now yeah now
he would pull out the bible and start
going into [ __ ] revelations he
again he was taking a little bit from
from here
you're not he was taking your case when
you do stuff like that you're just
what they call a country wit you know
what i'm talking about
yeah i know i i know exactly what you
mean yeah i had some relatives he
he was a country wit all right he was
somebody that you met
in a rural area who had an above average
intelligence
but they're you know pre-internet low
information society and the imagination
can kind of run
wild he wouldn't
the modern era would have changed his
thinking probably a lot
you know what i mean but that was this
was in a time when it was hard to find
information you remember what it was
like
yeah i know so yeah let's go ahead on
back to the show well sheila said
uh my mom gave us flat ginger ale when
we were sick yeah but mine too because
well because ginger does tend to like
settle your stomach down a little bit
like it's it's good for nausea that's
all it's for it's not curing anything it
just like
makes you feel a little less nauseous
um but yeah so okay so
so like i said nurse jensen has said
like i think it's the tylenol
the other doctors were kind of like
reluctant they're like you know what how
would they be getting it from that
but it happened that some enterprising
and uh prescient person that had
investigated the very first murder which
was a 12 year old girl
had actually taken the tylenol bottle
from their house
um just because i guess it was the last
thing that the girl had ingested so they
thought you know they took it like for
the crime scene
so it did actually so it was actually at
the hospital
or it was actually like in you know
police custody or whatever and they
could look at it
so they had it brought one second filthy
gardener and the quotation marks says
[ __ ] it above average iq
yeah you gotta understand the average iq
is like a hundred that's pretty [ __ ]
dumb
all right he was probably about 140 iq
he was smart
just like i said he was in his
60s you know 70s in the 80s you know i
mean it was that was that generation and
late 80s early 90s and and they just did
not have
the the modern information flow internet
has changed a lot
it's so much easier to research back in
those days you had to check out books
and
you could only get the books that were
in your library or things that you could
order and ordering [ __ ] was a [ __ ]
pain in the ass back then it wasn't like
they had
amazon so it was knowledge was a lot
harder to come by
all right so i do defend jim on that
level
he was intelligent it's just he didn't
have access to all the information
well and i mean i'm not sure access to
information because now we have access
to all the information but
that means that you also have access to
a bunch of [ __ ] information so it's
much easier to
like it's easier to find good
information but it's also much easier to
find bad information
too so in that way it's kind of like a
double-edged sword i would not go back
though because
there was shitty information back then
too it was just like harder to get any
information
i'm gonna go i'm just gonna go ahead and
quote [ __ ] quote [ __ ] obi-wan
kenobi
many of the truths we cling to depend
upon a certain point of view
there's enough information out there to
construct your own
series of events your own interpretation
of history
you know like this the islamic
interpretation of history is very
different
you know i mean than the western
interpretation of history same thing
with the chinese
you can construct a narrative out of
what's out there
you got to look at it that way you know
and it doesn't necessarily
mean that that version of history is is
false
it's just history from another
perspective with a different value
system
yeah because other civilizations and
other cultures have different value
systems
so i'm kind of fair when it comes to
that i'm not
into the solely western liberal
democracy
style perspective to things
because they're full of [ __ ] too you
know what i mean it's just
it depends on how you look at things
that's all i'm going to say
[Laughter]
all right so where was i okay so so the
nurse thought it was the tylenol like
the doctors at first didn't believe her
but then they started talking about
cyanide and they were like yeah the [ __ ]
does kind of sound like cyanide but
dr kim was kind of like yeah but where'd
they get it from
and all this other stuff so they're like
maybe we should check the victim's blood
it's like we've never done that before
our hospital doesn't have the facilities
to do that
so but he found out that there was like
another hospital like close by where
another lab close by where they could
send the blood so he's like okay well
let's do that
now interestingly the tylenol bottle
that they took from
the janus household and the tylenol
bottle
that was taken from the from mary
kellerman's house
like she was the first victim the 12
year old girl
one of the cops noticed that
both of these tylenol bottles had the
same
control number on them mc2880 so it was
like the same
lot number so and so
they thought that was like a little
suspicious so
the the medical examiner says to the guy
he's like okay well
open the pill bottles and smell them
what do you smell
so the investigator opened the bottles
and dumped him out he's like everything
looked
completely normal however when i smelled
it
there was a really strong smell of
almonds
and the other bottle same kind of thing
he's like he i opened it and it smelled
just like almonds
so he told the medical examiner this and
everybody
said cyanide now interestingly and i
actually did not know this until i
started research in this case because
if you've read any murder mysteries at
all or know anything about true crime
anytime somebody says bitter almonds you
always say like oh cyanide because
that's what it smells like
however what i didn't know was that only
about half of the population can smell
cyanide i didn't know that like the
other half apparently they don't have
that gene
weird yeah i just thought everybody
could smell it that that's what it
smelled like that's what i assumed
well that goes like cilantro yeah it's
kind of like that yeah
so some people i love cilantro and other
people they they it tastes like soap to
them
yeah but that it's like a gene it's like
a weird gene
i can [ __ ] put fresh cilantro in my
mouth and start chewing and think soap
and say yeah it kind of does taste like
soap but it doesn't it tastes good
to me it doesn't taste anything taste or
smell anything i can kind of see where
they're coming from but it's not the
same
but it is close although like i've and
i've mentioned this on the show before
like
mango to me tastes like perfect perfume
it does to me too but it tastes good
yeah to me it just tastes like
chemically like that okay no not but i
can
i can have things like i said because
like the indian restaurant we used to go
to sometimes like makes mango ice cream
in house and that's delicious
yeah that doesn't taste anything like
perfume okay but but a regular like if i
just eat like a mango like in
you know a fresh mango it smells and
tastes just like
chemical products okay you know how you
know how that ice cream tastes
to me a real mango tastes like that
just like that but with peach that's the
way a real mango tastes
interesting yeah yeah see it doesn't
taste like if you took that and peach
and put it together
that's what it tastes yeah i wish it
tasted like that to me but it just
tastes like
yeah it tastes like a chemical yeah
perfume yeah
yeah no it's like it's like peach with a
slight
rose hint yeah that's what it tastes
like
not to me okay that's really weird
though but yeah like you said cilantro
but like i said i didn't realize that
only half the population apparently
i think between 40 and 60 somewhere um
can actually smell cyanide as almonds so
they said they were really lucky like
that this
investigator on the case investigator uh
pishos i think his name was
um was actually able to tell because as
soon as he opened the bottles and like
dumped the [ __ ] out he's like oh my god
it smells like almonds so
everybody said cyanide so
basically so how cyanide works this is
really horrifying
so cyanide it's basically an asphyxian
okay it's like it's it blocks like
it blocks oxygen getting to your red
blood cells so it's like
you can be in a room with plentiful
oxygen like a regular room and yet you
will still
suffocate so it is like a really really
horrible
painful way to die
um you know you get and it happens like
very
very quickly obviously because these
people like took a tylenol and then like
minutes later
they collapsed on the ground and started
like [ __ ] having convulsions and [ __ ]
like that
and you know they were dead within like
an hour or two
so you know so you have cardiac ratio
brain damage it's very very fast
so thursday september 30th
so dr kim gets the lab reports back on
this blood test because he had taken
like the blood from some of the victims
that had died and had sent it out to
another lab
and they get the lab reports back very
early in the morning of september 30th
and they say that this was a massive
amount of cyanide they said it was
from a hundred to a thousand times more
than was necessary to kill a person
so this was just like a lot
in these [ __ ] things so uh that same
morning 3 15
am mary mcfarland who had been brought
in earlier uh she was also pronounced
dead at a hospital in downers grove
and later that same morning 9 30 a.m
mary reiner
is also pronounced dead so at this stage
because they have figured out that there
is cyanide in the tylenol
the first thing that they think is this
is like
um you know a manufacturing error like
some
like cyanide has fallen into the powder
somehow
and like gotten inside of the capsules
at first they were not thinking that it
was just some crazy person just like
putting cyanide in the capsules
they were thinking that this was some
kind of accident that had happened at
one of the
plants right so um
so that morning they get like an
attorney from johnson and johnson
who manufactured tylenol he shows up at
the office of the medical examiner
and uh so they had to explain to him
what was going on
and um he's like the emmy is like look
like we found cyanide in the tablets we
have to release this to the public
because this is a public health
issue it's like people we don't know how
much more of it is out there
um and we don't want anybody taking it
so we have to announce it
um and the obviously the dude from john
cena johnson was like
do we really have to do this and like
the guy was like yes we have to because
otherwise more people will die
so he's like okay fine so they have to
have a press conference
so they basically have a press
conference and they have to tell
everybody in the area chicago all the
outlining
outlying areas but it's like look if you
have any tylenol please don't take any
more because they
think that something happened with the
manufacturing process maybe some cyanide
somehow
got into the you know powder like inside
the capsules
so please don't take them we have to
warn the community about it
so basically then the nurse that first
figured out that it was probably the
tylenol caplets that had caused the [ __ ]
she says to the cops she's like look we
have to get all the tylenol in this area
off the shelves um the cops said
i don't think we can do that and she's
like we have to do that because we don't
know how much more of it is out there
so at this stage they were just kind of
like okay fine we got to do that the
police contact johnson and johnson
and to their credit johnson and johnson
were that very same day at 3 pm and this
was september 30th only a couple of days
after the first death
or actually only the next day actually
they said okay we're recalling
all of the tylenol from that lot because
at that time they just thought it was
that one lot that was
uh poison so
they said that like as that day went on
people kept calling because people were
like freaking out like once they
announced it to the public i mean as you
would so people
you know the dudes are like people are
calling me and being like oh my god i
took tylenol like yesterday and i'm am i
gonna die they're like look if you're
still talking to me right now you're not
gonna die it's like if you were gonna
die it would have happened immediately
um so you're probably fine just don't
take anymore
so that same day um they get
like uh teresa janus who was the wife of
stanley janus who had died earlier um
she had been on life support this entire
time they knew that she was not going to
recover so they took her off
life support and pronounced her dead 5
p.m
the police discovered the body of paula
prince who had died
uh the day prior but no one had known
you know they they didn't know because
like one of her friends
um i think she was supposed to like have
dinner or something with her sister and
she never turned up and nobody could get
in touch with her so they called the
cops for a welfare check
and then they found her in her house and
they found the bottle of tylenol assumed
that she had taken some
and that she was another victim of it
so um at this point so they go on tv
and uh they have the press conference
and then they release
uh they find security camera footage
this is what you were talking about
earlier yeah i saw this
it's been so long since i've seen this
yeah i thought he was kneeling down and
loading him up
i don't think he was kneeling i think he
was just behind but it's it's been a
long time since i've seen because i've
just seen like a couple of still photos
like in the yeah the resolution is [ __ ]
i mean well it's 1982. what's 82 and
it's probably a 70s
goddamn camera you can you couldn't see
[ __ ] you know
you know how it was but yeah so yeah so
it turns out that the walgreens that
paula prince
she was the flight attendant the
walgreens that she had been buying the
tylenol from they caught her on camera
like buying
the tylenol and they saw like a bearded
dude like behind her
kind of like he looked like he was you
know kind of [ __ ] with the tablets or
whatever
so they thought that maybe this was a
suspect they don't know if that was the
guy that did it or whatever but they
said he was just he was behind her
and so they presumed this is a suspect
so they kind of release that to the
public as well
now one thing that they did figure out
later on was that
whoever did this because like i said
initially they were thinking that it was
something that happened at the
manufacturing
process but as the investigation went on
and they determined
because the first two tylenol bottles
that they brought in and they tested
actually did happen to have the same lot
number on them
but as the investigation continued there
were more deaths
those tylenol bottles were from
different lot numbers and had been
uh manufactured at different facilities
so they're like okay well it's very
unlikely that this happened at the
manufacturing level because
somebody came in there and planted those
bottles yes so they're assuming at this
point like after they had figured that
out like after they had collected all
the
tylenol bottles from the desks they're
like what must have happened was that
this must be an individual or
individuals
who are going to the point of purchase
and are
taking the title they're probably
they're taking it off the show they're
stealing it or they're buying it
and then putting cyanide in some of the
caplets and then bringing it back to the
store and putting it back on the shelf
and they're like and he must have done
it in a pretty short time window because
after 48 to 72 hours the cyanide at
least the amount that the heat that he
was putting
into the caplets would have eaten
through the wax like the outside or the
whatever they use for the outside of the
caplet
so it's like so they are the capsule
rather so it's like it would have eaten
through that after
you know a day a few days so it's like
this must be a fairly recent
thing because what i think he was doing
is he was going to some place
buying a bottle of tylenol or a couple
bottles of tile at all
taking him back to his lair loading up
some of those [ __ ] capsules
going to another store not one and then
putting it back i'm just walking up
there and putting it in there i think
that's probably
that's that's because i think that's the
simplest way um
and back in the day you could do that
because
it's not like it was today for you
youngsters okay
back in the 70s and the early 80s a
video camera was like close to like five
or six hundred dollars a camera
they were more than that yeah and then
the central place to process it might be
like a two thousand dollar machine
so you were most stores maybe had like
three cameras
and the [ __ ] resolution was [ __ ] yeah
it's not like now wherever
cameras are cheap and they're everywhere
and crt television screens i mean you
know
real low resolution so you
so even if they got you on camera they
couldn't really make a positive id half
the time anyway
nowadays a camera is worth a penny
they're the size of a goddamn tic tac
and they're [ __ ] everywhere
eventually they're gonna be a [ __ ]
there's gonna be cameras in [ __ ]
sheets of paper
and they're going to be a chat and a lot
of them they have like facial
recognition yeah
you're not going to be able to escape
this is going to be one
big [ __ ] technological surveillance
state
you're going to be on camera everywhere
they're going to have [ __ ]
microscopic dust flying around
that has [ __ ] microchips in it and
cameras in it
that's they were actually talking about
that yeah you know about that yeah which
well like i said i can see that
happening
everything's just getting smaller and
smaller that covers the entire earth and
they will be able to access
everything everywhere and find any
object
everywhere on the earth you'll be able
to [ __ ] i really don't like that [ __ ]
that's some [ __ ] that batman would try
to stop
[Laughter]
remember remember when batman made the
[ __ ] machine that could hear
everybody talking and find you and hear
what you're saying
he did that they have that now he did
that [ __ ] to find the joker
and then once he found a joker and [ __ ]
the joker up he destroyed the machine
because you know this is too much power
we can't have this we can't have this
[ __ ] well no
big tech's going to make that [ __ ] it's
dangerous
it's it well see that's [ __ ]
unconstitutional it is and it's
well it's always kind of like it's kind
of it's kind of shitty because as
as me like someone that writes about
true crime and especially in this kind
of case
had we had the technology that we have
nowadays back then
this dude probably would have been
caught which he should have been because
he killed seven [ __ ] people that they
know of
all you need though you don't need a
[ __ ] hardcore surveillance state to
do that all you need is you need cameras
in all the parking lots and cameras in
all the stores
where civilization is that's where the
[ __ ] war that's where the
the [ __ ] is happening okay if you want
to put cameras
on your car then so be it yeah see i
don't have a problem with like you know
businesses and [ __ ] like that bring
cameras up but because they're
protecting their
bottom line i mean essentially yeah if
you want to put cameras around your
house then you go ahead
all right but the governments don't need
to be putting that [ __ ]
into dust and releasing it all over well
yeah because then it's like whoever is
in it's like they decide they don't like
some [ __ ] you said right then
when i was a kid you know the concept
that a computer chip and a camera
and a [ __ ] and and a microscopic
modem that can talk to the internet that
that would be the size of a [ __ ]
piece of
dust and one-tenth
the price of a sheet of paper that was
beyond me i never would have imagined
that [ __ ]
well and it happened very quickly never
and that's scary i mean like i said even
in our lifetimes
we remember you're right we i mean we
were kids but i still remember like i
was a kid or a teenager
i still remember like before there was
an internet before there was cameras
everywhere before there was anything
that's
[ __ ] no gps no nothing that is [ __ ] that
could not even be imagined and we're not
that old
that is [ __ ] that could not even be
imagined in star trek
well they start to imagine they didn't
even imagine that [ __ ] in star trek
i saw the star trek communicator when i
was a kid and go man i wish i had one of
those
and what we have today blows the [ __ ] of
star trek communication well yeah he
could just talk to the enterprise that's
all he can yeah there's no internet and
there's no screen on it
although i'm still mad we don't have a
transporter my [ __ ] my little [ __ ]
needs to get on
my little [ __ ] tablet is better
than mccoy's tricorder and just say that
about mccoy it has more knowledge in it
if as long as they got an internet
connection more knowledge than than
mccoy's tricorder
all i need is a way to cast cellular
energy into myself
to get an mri or a [ __ ] x-ray image
of my body
all right and then have an ai app
look for cancer or any problems in my
[ __ ] body
that's the next step you will totally
eliminate the need for hospitals and
doctors i'm kind of down for that
because i think it would be really cool
if you could diagnose your immune
diagnosis go oh [ __ ]
take oh [ __ ] i got cancer
and then you [ __ ] show that picture
to a doctor i got cancer hello
yeah i'll [ __ ] get the nanites yeah
get the nanites
send me the [ __ ] what do i need send
me the prescription
you know i'll [ __ ] send you the money
to paypal that's the way it should be
done
i'm i'm down i'm done that's coming yeah
that's not that like far out
i got a robot that [ __ ] does my blood
pressure i got a little thing
i got a little thing that does my blood
sugar i'm constantly going in there
check checking i'm [ __ ]
i'm straight that technology
back in the 70s would have been [ __ ]
something space age
we're living and everyone's just kind of
like meh
yeah like meh well because i mean
it happened so quickly that like people
that are a lot younger than us they
don't realize
they were i mean they grew up with
computers so it's like
i didn't really i didn't get a computer
until i was i didn't see a computer
until i was eight
well we grew up with and then it was
like an apple 2e yeah we grew up with
computers they just weren't they were
just very
they were just shitty they were weak you
couldn't do much with them because like
i said
i started using them when i was eight in
school so like in 1970
yeah no 1980 1980 i didn't really
i didn't really understand
i really didn't grasp what was going on
until about
96. yeah i don't think anybody really
grasped like the
you know how much it was going to change
everything i bought a web tv
and from tv i could access the internet
and that blew me away because
i could do without a computer yeah and
then
i could with and very rapidly with my
bank
card buy things from [ __ ] hot topic
[Laughter]
without having to go to the store and i
was blown away i thought i was
arnold schwarzenegger out of [ __ ] out
of [ __ ]
that one movie where he buys that
[ __ ] plane ticket what was the name
of that [ __ ]
that was uh running man no it wasn't
running it wasn't running man
oh no no no it was it was the one where
he goes to mars
get your ass to mars total recall
i thought i was in total recall man i
was buying [ __ ]
and you used it to buy [ __ ] from hot tub
from hot topic at least he didn't buy
jenko pancakes i
wrote some sexy ass [ __ ] sexy ass
goth clothes and [ __ ] that's back when
the hot topic had goth clothes
they did i remember buying actual good
golf clothes good guys like corsets and
stuff
yeah you get the 20-hole doc martens and
everything yeah they used to have good
shapes big the big tie dot
big tall i guess it didn't sell enough
though because like after a while they
just kind of went it's like well you
know what we're just gonna sell a bunch
of t-shirts
all right look i gotta tell you guys a
story uh-oh
about hot topic is this about the big
pants yeah it's about the big fan
[Laughter]
okay i know this story and i was living
in biloxi
uh my ex-wife's
best friend was named melissa and
melissa worked at hot topic
down in biloxi and she and she was a
goth check hardcore gotcha
the people that owned hot topic were
gods all right
and they [ __ ] liked her and they
ended up promoting her to like a
regional manager and she ends up going
to this big [ __ ] meeting
at uh someplace near their headquarters
they flew her down there
and they had a big meeting about look we
need some golf clothes that we can sell
to the masses
and this is what they're wearing right
now and they showed pictures of jankos
so we're gonna make a goth version of
that and they were laughing and
snickering
like no one's gonna wear those and they
came up with the most ridiculous designs
all right and and that's what ended up
being popular man we started seeing that
[ __ ] at the club and that was made it a
joke as a joke
by the people that owned hot tub well i
always saw it we thought they were
[ __ ] crazy
they had a contest
remember the contest come up with the
stupidest [ __ ] stupidest they said
once you get these kids and sell them
[ __ ] these outfits
and take pictures of them whoever can
make the most ridiculous kid will get a
[ __ ] uh
a bonus and they were
[Laughter]
and they were bringing kids in and
putting big [ __ ] jacobs on them and
[ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] mixtures of
[ __ ]
[ __ ] spray coloring their hair and
[ __ ] and that's
putting them in high heel shoes and send
them down the middle of the mall
and go yeah man you look fantastic look
awesome and the [ __ ] people were
laughing at him they come back i don't
know man people are [ __ ] reacting
bad to this i don't know
they were taking pictures of them at the
main office
and in a competition and who can make
the most [ __ ] up kid is [ __ ]
ridiculous man
i mean i gotta say like not to [ __ ] on
any little baby bats or little emo kids
or anything
but us cranky old goths yeah they were
old like even in the
back in those days we were getting older
we were like these kids i when i
was at the castle in the 90s and the
2000s you'd see
like these kids showing up in these
giant pants and everything and all of us
old people were like just laughing their
asses off at you guys proto emos
emos were actually we were just like
look at that
they were they were a joke that was
created by hot dogs and i didn't even
know
like before i met you that that's what
that was but i was just like well
because
like all the ol all the elder goths were
like laughing at that [ __ ] because
executives at hot time they just called
him the mall goths yeah
executives at hot tub or the mansonites
yeah yeah
executives at the hot topic did that
[ __ ] as a gag
we just thought that was hilarious and
we're like oh here is here's these kids
again holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
because you know how [ __ ] gods are
we're so like [ __ ] and catty
especially like old ones like us
yeah louie hernandez and mark they're
going yeah it's total recall yeah
i feel like i was in total recall man
[ __ ] i was i thought i was in the
future
it was tripping me the [ __ ] out yeah
i thought i was in the future and then
they had [ __ ] chat
rooms and then you went in some of those
and then a friend of mine called me
over his phone through my computer
and he wasn't he didn't even have to pay
long distance charges i was tripping
remember that i know so because remember
yeah remember back in the old days when
you actually like had to pay
somebody that was outside of your city
yeah yeah they caught paid long distance
charges
yeah he got around those long distance
charges in my mind nobody does that [ __ ]
anymore
you just skype that [ __ ] it's free
which is crazy i mean that's better
because i used to suck man like even
when i was because it was long distance
outside of your city even if i called my
mom
like a couple cities away it was like
[ __ ] i don't even remember how much
it was it was like [ __ ]
well it was like a few dollars and then
it was like so many cents like per
minute it was like really yeah business
you're right man that [ __ ] was running
man
he escaped it was running man it was not
total recall he escaped from prison and
went to the [ __ ] mexican girl's house
and [ __ ] tried to book that that was
a total recall no
that was not total recall that that was
running man
that was running man because he booked
the flight
i don't know why not to mars he booked
it to hawaii he was trying to run
but he didn't make it to hawaii
you're right man i thought it was
business right
jim trucker asks have y'all ever looked
at the highway 20 killings
no but i i actually am planning to do
another highway murders
show because we did one a while back i
think i talked about the colonial
parkway killer
and maybe the texas killing fields i
can't remember but um i wanted to do
another because there's like a really
lot of like unsolved
highway murders yeah so
are we done with big pants yeah we're
done with big pants we're done running
man
okay it was running man i know it was
running man maybe it was i don't know he
escaped from prison and he went to
[ __ ]
maria conchita's house what the name
maria conchita maria conchita alonso
and that her name yeah mariachita alonso
yeah went to her house
she was a cute cute hispanic chick and
like threatened her and
yeah he was like you're gonna do you you
and i'd be like no
get out i'm calling the police and then
he used her credit card to buy the damn
again calling the police well yeah
it didn't matter because he was already
on the run from the police
remember he escaped from prison and then
he used the [ __ ]
he swiped the card to buy a ticket to
hawaii but
that didn't work and then then she found
out that he was uh he was in there on
false charges that he was actually
innocent he didn't massacre all those
people
they set him up for it remember he was
the army guy
mark asked if you would go gay for arnie
no would not go get a ferrari only
only david bowie he would go gay for
david bowie in
the [ __ ] jareth outfit well not now
cause he's dying
but i'm talking like in in the [ __ ]
in the [ __ ]
that was actually jenny jenny invented
that [ __ ] that's my idea that was her
idea
then what no i got drunk one time and
[ __ ] this is right after this is
right after [ __ ] david bowie died
yeah we were up at the bar we were at
eye bar and it was everyone but everyone
was like crying
well because i bar is like you know it's
like 80s retro night it's like and they
were playing like all david bowie songs
and i was just like crying and i was
like
would you have sex with that man for me
and i was i started [ __ ] with it i
was like
only if he was in that jareth outfit
from [ __ ] from ulta okay
from the labyrinth she's like yeah yeah
all right yeah i started just like
pouring it on i was trying to feed her
fantasy
although i would have also accepted um
the outfit
from the fashion video or
the ashes to ash's video yeah i would
have accepted that harlequin
sure yeah i like that too yeah well
that man his final words was is uh
tell them i was a closeted heterosexual
yeah that was his final words tell them
i was a closeted head
that's awesome and in his last video he
goes back into the closet
remember that that's a you know what i
think that might be even better
than my previously favorite last words
which were those of oscar wilde who
reportedly said
either these curtains go or i do yeah
and then he died then he died
yeah because
i mean it's obvious it's obvious once
once you
[ __ ] do any research on bowie
bowie was pioneering a lot of [ __ ]
he was not gay he was pretending to be
gay he knew how to choke
he was pansexual yeah but i don't know
he was
he was actually having sex with guys i i
think he just knew how to play and a lot
of people have said this that he knew
how to play
the gay aristocracy and that's who was
backing a lot of his artistic endeavors
and his career he
they loved him so well and you have to
think too that in the 70s
it was very chic yeah it was like super
high class
well to be just like pansexual just to
be like oh whatever
he was a man whatever he's a man of his
tongue you know what i mean so
it was very chic in this it was a
romanesque personality
sure great artist
an artiste you might want to say yeah
so uh okay so where was i we're talking
about a horrible case okay calm down
[Laughter]
what's that although now they're asking
if i'd have sex with crossover and [ __ ]
like
you guys are trying to sexualize things
oh the new christmas chronicles is
coming out you guys november 25th
yeah i just i just thought it was
chronicles part part two
yeah yeah goldie han is in it too
playing mrs claus
those are like the closest thing to like
a new classic
yeah we have something to watch on
christmas christmas movies real good
christmas movie i'm gonna watch that
and i'm gonna watch the two mst
christmas oh no actually three christmas
if you have not seen christmas
chronicles one you should see it
yeah the second one the trailer just
went up november 25th it's coming
russell and his wife
goldie hawn goldie is playing miss mrs
claus
she looks great looks like she just had
some work done on her face she looks
good
and they're gonna the adventure takes
place in the north pole with the same
kids
that's pretty awesome that they got the
same kids back the same kids back
i mean i guess the old one's not really
a kid but you know like a real good
spielberg christmas style spielberg
style christmas movie
without any of the [ __ ] you know
it's crustal
santa claus carries a 45. well and i
particularly like in the first one that
santa got to go to jail
and hang out with hookers yeah and they
they were doing the background
backup vocals for it yeah because yeah
because that's what you need a christmas
movie
that's how crustal is going to roll you
want santa being in jail with him
yeah yeah and it's not yeah and don't
think don't think i'm saying it's like
it's some kind of subversion of
of it's 100 christmas 100 percent
it does it puts me in the mood it just
puts me in the christmas mood he just
got thrown into jail because he was
trying to save christmas but he gets out
of jail
the cops let him out because he's able
to he he he would convince
them that he was santa claus because he
knew what toys they all wanted
when they were kids he had all the toys
in his pocket of what they wanted when
they were kids that's right
you can pull a toy out yeah that's
pretty rad yeah
that was such a good movie i hope the
second one's good too i mean i'm sure it
will be but yeah it's crustal
i'm just i'm excited about it i just
found out yesterday that it was coming
out
i was looking so okay so at this point
like i said they figured out that it's a
tylenol they figured out that it was
cyanide
fourth drove down so bowie and jagger
just wanted to get drunk take drugs
and [ __ ] groupies everything else is
just to sell records
they knew how to play the media they
knew how to [ __ ] keep everything
interesting and keep everybody [ __ ]
guessing about who they were
music culture back in the day was their
version of social media
i remember what it was like not to have
internet you got your information in the
vibe
and the scene came from what was
happening in albums
that was that was our social media back
then but times have changed
but in those days man those guys were on
top of the game
and jagger man [ __ ]
that dude's a [ __ ] living legend i
can't believe he's still alive
i can't believe any of them he was like
70 and still
[ __ ] dancing and rocking skinny and
[ __ ] [ __ ] heroine man
he just sleeps i guess i'm telling you
like a vampire
tempting i gotta make another drink one
other drink yeah
good good all right let's get the show
back on track because we [ __ ] the show
up
we yeah we did
all right so where was i so like i said
so now i will say
as shitty as a lot of uh responses are
to this type of public crisis not
mentioning anything in particular
um but i'm just saying that i will say
that in 1982 i do admire
the speed with which they got on this
[ __ ]
not only did johnson and johnson
immediately like the day
after they found out that it was like
tylenol and there was sign at it
they pulled all the [ __ ] they recalled
everything and uh
everybody in chicago all the authorities
and everything they basically they had
flyers printed up in like every
imaginable language
they had cars out with [ __ ]
loudspeakers and [ __ ] like that like
telling everybody don't take the tile at
all there's poison in it it's like so
they really
did make an effort and the cop said at
the time it's like look we were
you know we yes obviously we were
interested in catching whoever the [ __ ]
was doing this but it's like
our number one priority was like warning
everybody not to take any more we didn't
want any more deaths
so they really did they really were on
the ball for this which
is a nice change um you know because
like i said a lot of these cases
you know it's they just wait until it's
too late or they just don't want to do
anything or anything but on this one
they seem like they were really really
on the ball
as soon as they figured out what was
going on
so that yeah so they go to the press uh
they go to the press they take all the
[ __ ] off the shelves
um and basically a couple of days after
this was october 4th which i think was
only like five or six days like after
the first death
um the mayor of chicago major burn
thank you um she basically came out and
passed an
ordinance saying okay well all drugs
sold in stores now have to have tamper
resistant packaging so that was like
immediate
um you know really on the ball
so johnson and johnson on the fifth they
recall um at first they were only
recalling the tylenol that was that
lot number but once they you know looked
further into the thing and like the [ __ ]
was coming from a lot of different lot
numbers
so they said okay basically we have to
take all of this off the shelves
everywhere
so they took all tylenol products off
the shelves
all over the country uh this was 31
million bottles
valued at more than 100 million dollars
which is almost 300 million dollars in
today's money
so basically so like i said you
you have all this [ __ ] going on now they
now they start to concentrate once they
have the public informed and they think
that that's
fine they're like okay now we're gonna
try and figure out like
who the [ __ ] is is doing this so he said
now we did get a bunch of leads
uh in the first few days like so many
that they were like having a hard time
like
keeping track of all of them so it's
like we got all these wackos like
calling saying they did it it's like
they had to investigate every single one
and like none of them were that but you
know
so he's got thousands of leads so
basically that's like this is going on
for a couple weeks
um you know the story is obviously huge
news
everyone is super paranoid they don't
want to take any
drugs now because it's like taking
something
i mean just popping a [ __ ] aspirin or
taking a tylenol it's just something
people do every day you don't really
think about it
um and the fact that you could just like
take a couple tylenol because you got a
headache and then like two hours later
you could be [ __ ] dead
um that's really freaking some people
out you know like
understandably so this was like a huge
[ __ ]
media circus so
basically they're like the first thing
that they thought of
they're like well we know that this
probably didn't happen
at the manufacturing point because it
was like too many different facilities
that we're talking about
so like maybe this is somebody that
worked for johnson and johnson in the
past and was like
disgruntled like a disgruntled employee
now there there had been a problem with
johnson and johnson in the past
um maybe you guys have uh heard about it
but they were getting in trouble because
of their like talcum powder because
their talcum powder had like this
like mold stuff growing in it and they
thought that it was like giving people
uh
cancer like it particularly gave women
like ovarian cancer and stuff like that
there are still as far as i know there
are still like a lot of uh pending
lawsuits about that kind of [ __ ]
where they think like this is unlikely
well no it's it's this particular type
of mold that got
into their towel into their talcum
powder that um they think was causing
this really high incidence of um like
certain types like
ovarian cancer cervical cancer stuff
like that in women that were using it
um so there was that whole kind of [ __ ]
going on
so they investigated like a bunch of
ex-employees
um they couldn't really find a whole
bunch of stuff
you know going on there however then an
interesting development
october 6th they get a letter
um the cops get a letter
or no jonathan johnson gets a letter and
it's basically an extortion letter
it says that um
i will stop the killings if you give me
a million dollars and it basically like
said it like
set out like how he did it and it's like
it's very easy to do
it only takes 10 minutes i can do it in
my car blah blah blah
and it's like you know just um i'll keep
doing it unless you send me a million
dollars
so the cops investigate this letter that
johnson and johnson had gotten
now they traced this letter to a dude
named james lewis who lived in new york
city
so they're like investigating him for a
while he gets picked up in
december now i want to talk more about
him later
because he's still kind of the prime
suspect
um but i don't know was i i'm not sure
how i feel about him as a suspect i'm
kind of leaning more toward maybe he is
but the thing about it is that
opinions are divided with the
investigators over whether this dude
was involved or not because it could be
that he was just like some extortionist
who was just like took advantage of
a situation at large and actually sure
yeah
um but which is what i kind of thought
but then i found out some more [ __ ]
about him that they don't mention on
wikipedia or anything like that
and then i was like oh well maybe that
makes it more likely that he did
something like this
that'd be some risky [ __ ] because
[ __ ] you're sitting there sending
letters and if you get caught then you
go down for the murders
so that's picking up some serious
charges just to make a million dollars
i mean you might as well just do it you
know what i mean
well yeah and i'm kind of like okay so a
couple of people in there i found like
this um timeline that i think it was in
the chicago reader and they had like a
bunch of investigators on the case like
talking about him as a suspect
now one of the guys like outright says
it wasn't him
um he was just an opportunist he called
him an [ __ ] he said he was just
looking for an opportunity to like
extort some money on johnson and johnson
but i don't think he was the one
responsible for the poisoning
um now another guy the attorney general
he actually does think this guy not only
sent the extortion letter which they
know he did because they found his
[ __ ] uh fingerprints and [ __ ]
on it but also he thinks that he was
responsible for the poisonings
but we'll talk about that in a minute so
basically um actually let me
take a break because i gotta pee okay
but don't tell everybody you got to pay
due
i'm just telling you do you want to talk
or do you want me to run
a couple go ahead and run the
commercials well i only have one
commercial in one pokey video so it's
only like
maybe in a minute and 30 seconds show me
the lot show me uh
okay so you got like fv commercial there
and then pokey
okay i'll do it so do those two and then
if you want to come back so i'm gonna go
to the bathroom going to commercial
you love true crime i love true crime
and i've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing
unsolved murders of the 20th century
it's called the faceless villain
and volume 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the ketty
murders the carrie babies case
the frog boys the alcasar murders and
the anoka shira park dismemberment
incident
the faceless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999.
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com and get ready for a chilling
journey through modern crime history
[Music]
do
[Music]
you love true crime i love true crime
and i've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the ketty
murders the carrie babies case the frog
boys
the alcasar murders and the anoka shira
park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999.
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com and get ready for a chilling
journey through modern crime history
[Music]
so he said that he played the
commercials twice did you seriously do
that
i was shaming i didn't want to talk but
no i mean
i did went through that one and then
went back to the commercial i said i'm
gonna replug
plug man didn't plug i didn't talk about
flash bulbs
or getting people [ __ ] coming back on
patreon we need more patron supporters
because he told me the super chats we
need all that we got to start
plugging because we don't plug enough
we don't well because we're not because
we just we do this for fun and we're not
greedy it's like
you know we we like like getting money
from the show but it's like
i don't know i always feel really like
skeezy like yeah and then i said [ __ ] it
i want to i want to see pookie again
because
you're the one that filmed pookie on
that we got a new camera yeah
that was like a test we got this we got
a new camera yeah
but look it's got microphones it's got a
microphone and everything so
we take better and i just and i just
took like a test of i just i put music
over it because the audio didn't come
out because i
forgot to turn the mic yeah you called
it that was pookie being suspicious she
looks at the camera like what the [ __ ]
is this
[ __ ] you looking at me for i'm in my
room get that [ __ ] out of here she was
mad because she was in her apartment and
i was like
hey what do you do because during the
day she doesn't roll do like a lot of
exciting [ __ ] because she usually just
sleeps
if you try to like videotape her while
she's sleeping she just looks at you
like yeah
yeah she just gives you that [ __ ]
face
we got some new shirts coming soon and
we're gonna [ __ ]
stir up the [ __ ] shirt excitement
gonna be some real
yeah gonna be some real good designs you
guys gonna like
and you can uh get those for a 20 super
chat
and uh one of them is going to be like a
506 shirt from my unit
to you infantry cross rifles on it
that shirt will probably be a od green
shirt we got od green right we can
we can order those right i can get those
yeah yeah i can get anything i get from
jiffyshirts.com that one should be on od
green or gray
all right and then uh we're gonna have a
canon film
canon mark said i want i want an it's a
movie shirt
we oh that's right we need to make one
where you kept saying like
it sure is a movie it sure is a movie i
was probably [ __ ] loaded and just
trying to come up with something you
know i mean
now when i should i put okay let me ask
you guys
on these shirts should you have my
[ __ ] crazy ass
on the shirt maybe with a facial
expression that matches that
or do you want just a saying i was
thinking about just putting me on the
shirt
because i want like crazy i want a
picture of you making a face because i
i told you i said i need a good picture
of you making it like a funny face like
with your mouth open or something
so then i can put i say whatever comes
out of my mouth
zach asks what our thoughts are on
hawaiian pizza oh yes indeed
i actually love hawaiian pizza i know a
lot of people don't and i know it's cool
to like wish death
upon people that don't like it yes
indeed i think it's good i love it
it's not my favorite i make it but yeah
it's not my favorite like it's not the
first thing i would pick but if somebody
had some hawaiian pizza [ __ ] yeah i mean
the saltiness of the ham mixed with the
sweetness
of the [ __ ] pineapple hell yeah i
will say though that when i was in the
uk
one uh pizza topping i found very weird
was sweet corn
no not good not good which no
yeah okay i'm not like i said i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna [ __ ] on people for liking
that it's like whatever
they had shrimp on there too but i can
get behind that because i used to go to
[ __ ]
what was that chain that used to like
pizzeria uno or whatever my brother used
to work there a long time ago
and they had like a really really nice
like chicago style shrimp pizza
and i was into that zack's eating he's
eating papa john's right now that's
that's my favorite
fast food pizza papa john's is kind of
like
like the owner of it is a douche but
like the why's he douche
i don't know he's just douchey in
general but um
of all the fast food pizza they're all
passable
papa john's is probably my favorite yeah
well just because um
like i said the older i get like and i
love tomato sauce so this sucks but
tomato sauce gives me really bad
heartburn
so it's like generally the sweeter the
tomato sauce is the less heartburn it
gives me so like the ones that are more
like acidic
so i feel like dominoes and pizza hut
have more acidic sauces and
papa john's is like sweeter or milder so
it doesn't like mess up my stomach as
much
well you don't you know you don't
[ __ ] do what i tell you
i said you know put a little bit of that
baking soda
put a little bit of baking soda or yeah
baking soda baking powder baking soda
in water and i know you tell but i'm not
doing that because it's gross
it takes it away we usually have tums
but we're out yeah we're out of those
and he always buys the gross fruit ones
where i always want the peppermint ones
yeah [ __ ] that peppermint no i like the
peppermint
i like them my i want my [ __ ] to taste
like tricks
cereal yeah why are you so fruity i
don't know man
it's the man in me i guess because men
like fruity flavors we don't like those
chocolatey minty
girl type flavors with caramel we like
it it's just
we tend more towards sherbet skittles
starburst you know what i mean tart
stuff
i like that i'm not into it like i don't
hate it like i'll take them but if i
have the choice i would rather have
something like chocolatey or nutty or
caramelly or minty if you just let a
woman alone she's going to make
something like a [ __ ] hot fudge
brownie
that's what she's going to make she's
going to take some brownies and we're
the worst
and put another pour the hot fudge and
then put the coffee ice cream on them
and put chocolate chips on that [ __ ] i'm
gonna put like
walnuts on that [ __ ] that's what's gonna
happen yeah
but it's good all right it's not bad i'm
just saying
you you just eat like a big pile of
jujubes or something
that's [ __ ] disgusting and then
you'll get the [ __ ]
no no it's normal no really it's the
gummy bears what was it that it was the
gummy bears that were like sugar-free
the sugar-free gummy bears
i haven't either but like the am good
like a laxative go to the amazon reviews
for the sugar-free gummy bears and read
the reviews they are
hilarious because apparently i don't
know how true a lot of the stuff is but
once one person
said they acted like a laxative and like
they [ __ ] out a penny that they ate when
they were three or something like that
it's like they are [ __ ] funny
i don't know is it well it's because i
guess it's got aspartame in it and i
guess that's like a laxative
everybody's talking about pizza when the
when um
we're gonna get we're gonna get on the
[ __ ] um
the uh the recipe book there's gonna be
a whole pizza
well after halloween like cause like i
said i got it set up i just need you to
sit down and like
go through all the [ __ ] and make sure
it's all right i'm a pizza fanatic
my pizza is better than most pizza well
easily i know how to make it
i make the sauce and make the [ __ ]
dough and i make all that
there's a secret to all that [ __ ] i'm
gonna pass it along to you
once you get the set up right you can
make a pizza friend [ __ ] nothing
as long as you can get your hands on
bread flour you can't get it on any
any old kind of flour bread flour
i think really per pizza if you probably
break it down
how much it costs for me to make say
like just just a regular pepperoni pizza
a big one it would be like a large
because my pizza peel to get it on the
stone really i'm limited to that
oh yeah want a [ __ ] huge peel and a
huge stone
so i could put an extra large in there
but i say like a large pizza
i'm making that for maybe like 75 cents
it's not expensive at all that's just
all that shit's cheap
i mean unless you get well the cheese
that probably bumps up to about a dollar
yeah i mean because you can get the big
bag
of like part skim like mozzarella
yeah that's the cheapest way which is
the cheapest way which is fine
but if you want to really you have to
get like the little cakes of like the
buffalo mozzarella which is really but
it's like
how much that's like eight or nine bucks
for two little cakes right
now you can that'll make one or two
pizzas you can make that at home
you can we haven't yet though but i've
calculated all the cost
you got to use cheesecloth you got to
use lemon you got to use
milk and [ __ ] to make it there's a
certain kind of bacteria we
need i researched but it ends up being
where
it's about the same price just to buy it
yeah
you know so
although i may have to i'm gonna have to
look back into it just have to see but
the last i
the last i looked at making your own
mozzarella
is about the same as buying it you know
so it's kind of expensive to make too
i mean the same thing with ice cream
yeah you can make your own ice cream but
you can't beat the price of bluebell
it's expensive to make your own ice
cream it's all the eggs
yeah eggs and sugar and [ __ ] a lot
[ __ ] ton of cream
we used to have an ice cream maker and
it was like it was nice
but yeah in the end it was just like
easier it's easier and cheaper it's
really not expensive to buy bluebell ice
cream which is some of that's the best
and um publix brand
their brand ice cream they got their own
creamery publix brand ice cream is
[ __ ] fantastic
it really is they're sure it's good and
they put them on sale like all the time
you get like two for what is it like two
for eight bucks
yeah so you're just not gonna be able to
beat their prices
i mean if you like to make ice cream
like we used to like to make it in the
summer sometimes like especially my
grandma used to make it with like fresh
peaches and stuff oh yeah yeah
same thing in mississippi [ __ ] when
the peaches started to get over right
yeah
pick them off the back yeah and you make
ice cream you're sure my grandma did
that peach ice cream you people would
not [ __ ] understand they'll that's
only a season all day
mississippi peach ice cream another one
that we used to do
is make orange ice cream not on sherbet
but orange ice ice cream because we had
oranges
yeah we had a tree in there really good
yeah oranges on it really good
we gotta get back miss the food i know
show always end up talking about food
yeah good because we're hungry yeah but
yeah so like i said so as the
basically like a month after the last
death
um they had pretty much exhausted all of
their leads so it's like they had like a
task force and everything
that was originally like 100 something
guys like 115 guys or something
and like after that they were just kind
of like okay well we exhausted all the
leads so
the task force was kind of like taken
out of nothing
um they did however find like
they they pulled a bunch of bottles off
the shelves because they were looking
for other contaminated bottles obviously
um they actually found uh
so the five bottles that you know
actually killed people um
they actually found three bottles that
had poisoning that were still
on the shelf going on about my arms and
[ __ ] and saying i'm sexy and that i
gotta smell like perfume did you say i
smelled like perfume
i didn't say that we were talking about
we were talking about the mangoes
mangoes taste mangoes
tasting like yeah i don't i don't smell
like i mean
i do wear cologne but i wear obsession
you smell like
obsession yeah yeah she loves that
[ __ ] smell
that's an old man fragrance now i don't
even think young guys know about
obsession that [ __ ]
obsession this just smells good man it
does smell good yeah well i kind of like
well in perfume too it has to like react
with your natural like body scent
yeah because some people can wear
particular perfumes or colognes they're
all perfumes come on
they only call it cologne because they
gotta get men to buy it you're right
but it's all the same [ __ ] yeah but it's
like so it has to like react
correctly like with your body chemistry
because otherwise it's gonna smell weird
or off
yeah so but when you find the right
synergy
because i feel like you and obsession
are a good
match is that what it is my pheromones
huh yeah
well no because that was one of the
things that like you know when i first
met you i was like man he smelled good
yeah because and it was because of
obsession but it was also kind of like
how it was working
it smells like spices and vanilla which
i like
yeah i don't like really i don't like
florally kind of stuff unless it's
um i like orange blossomy type of smells
but i don't really like
like gardenia i don't like that floral
kind of thing i like
musky kind of smells or like vanilla or
wood or something
yeah it's obsession is powerful
but not skanky like [ __ ] patchouli
even though i kind of although i admit i
kind of like with julie but
we know it's just like a friend of mine
every time i smell butchu they expect to
see a hippie
or something you know well it it it got
unfairly associated with put
with hippies and i think a lot of people
like don't like it because of that but i
actually like the way patchouli smells
um we have a friend though i know i'm
dealing with a [ __ ]
we have a friend i'm
we have a friend and he loves patchouli
oil yeah
and i like that smell so it's like every
time we we see him out and he's like a
total he's a goofball he's he's awesome
like i really like him but um
but he always wears it so it like
reminds me of him now because
he's always wearing it and he's like
drunk on tequila every time we see him
and he's like a total whack job
but uh so that reminds me of him but i
really like the way patchouli smells and
i really like another
smell that i really like too is um
dragon's blood
which you can get i don't think they put
in any colognes or anything but you can
buy it like an essential oil
and you can get uh what do you call it
[ __ ]
uh what's stuff that you burn like
incense you can get incense it smells
like because i used to have these little
purple cones that smelled like that nice
so my apartment used to smell like that
look at this [ __ ] listen to this [ __ ]
sandra's in there trying to pimp me out
saying if you paid give tom a [ __ ] 10
super chat he takes his shirt off
i don't though because you did that that
one time yeah i think it was 20.
i think it was 20 i think it was 20. if
i remember correctly we were pretty
drunk on that
yeah i'm not really [ __ ] pumped up i
haven't lifted in a week
i was going through well you're going
through your hormonal changes i was
going through i went through it
i went through a [ __ ] deep a
de-stressed week
where i just sit there and just grow for
about a week
i got bigger did get bigger
now i'm gonna i'm gonna just be off of
it for
probably another two weeks and then i'm
gonna go back on a cycle
disarm cycle for about another month
probably lgd 40 33 that's a good sign
i got a lot of rad 140 too i need to use
up
it's it's some [ __ ] you know i mean this
is a new era back in the day
dudes would not give up their stack they
would not tell people
any kind of performance enhancing drugs
they were ashamed of that [ __ ]
but all those new guys are trying to
break that taboo
it's the same with women all right women
have been [ __ ] with their hormones to
prevent pregnancy or look pretty or
do whatever they've been doing this [ __ ]
for [ __ ] ever all right
it's the same thing in a way women
[ __ ] been getting breast implants
they do [ __ ] you know i mean it's
cosmetic stuff
there are certain [ __ ]
compounds out there that'll help a
[ __ ] heal up
which means that you can work out a lot
which means you get big
because you can work out more than you
normally would
a guy at 51 working out the [ __ ] i
would not be able to keep up with my
[ __ ] workout routines without
some kind of [ __ ] aid i mean i
half the time i got a metabolic rate of
a 20 year old
because of this the metabolic rate of a
51 year old i'm a 51 actually all right
i think i'm 51 50. you don't even know
yeah i don't know
i don't give a [ __ ] biologically i feel
like i'm a lot older you are 51 yeah i'm
51 yeah because you were born in 1969
yeah and it's 20 20. as as much as i
lift as hard as i work i'll work out to
the [ __ ] bone
it would take me two weeks to [ __ ]
heal up after that
and he like seriously you moan enough
taking the [ __ ]
yeah oh
[Laughter]
the more muscle you have the more
the more you have to work it out and the
more it takes to [ __ ] tear it all up
to grow some to fix it and then
you know what i mean you only got one
metabolism but you got five four times
the amount of muscle you had three or
four years ago you got to to heal it up
it's a lot of
it you guys are look man i'm giving you
giving away too many goddamn secrets to
you people
all right this is [ __ ] that you really
you should have a [ __ ] trainer to
teach you all this [ __ ]
all right it's all out there now it's
all out in the open
[ __ ] they used to have dudes like me
on [ __ ] hollywood and they look at
that muscle man or whatever they were
[ __ ] much bigger than me and it was a
secret
how that [ __ ] gets so big that's all
on youtube now
and instagram they'll tell you
you get big by [ __ ] lifting lots of
weight a lot a lot of it you tear the
[ __ ] out of yourself
and then you just heal up and it gets
bigger
but just lay around and go wait around
sit around and eat like a damn lion and
resting and just growing like a lion you
know
you become a lying [ __ ] it's
sexy as [ __ ] it is
i was a lion [ __ ] though years
back though that's not the kind of line
i'm talking about
sitting around like a [ __ ] tiger
growing and [ __ ] that's what you
would do he would go
he would go to the chinese buffet we
should go to the chinese cafe
yeah i would eat like a couple plates be
like man i'm gonna throw up i can't eat
anymore yeah he would go like
he would go eat sushi he did a big pile
of like shrimp
i'm like and i'd be like look at him
across the table
where are you putting that yeah like i'm
shrimp is pure protein
i'm gonna barf if i eat anything shrimp
is pure protein it's very low calorie
you eat i've tried i tried to eat like
[ __ ] five pounds of shrimp
those chinese saw me coming here like
put the sign up put the sign
up no closed because they know i'm gonna
[ __ ] break them that's what i mean
i'm gonna eat all the shrimp all the
boiled shrimp well you better save some
for me [ __ ] and i was sitting
there eating once i'm sharing some
scallops
i'm risking the [ __ ] diseases you get
but what i was saying is it's all it's
all out there and open now to
destigmatize
it's just modern technology everything's
in those and there's a big difference
between abuse and use of these kind of
compounds
no i don't same with everything yeah you
jump on gear at [ __ ]
15 you're just broided the [ __ ] out
you'll get [ __ ] huge in a few years
you will be
[ __ ] up by 30 mostly all right just
but you could do it the jack lalanne way
where you [ __ ] stay healthy and
you're
you're not really doing much you're just
working out until you get old and then
you just use the [ __ ]
for therapeutics to maintain which is
more what i do
all right and [ __ ] jack elaine lived
to his
early 90s and he looked good all the way
to his 90s there's a way to prolong [ __ ]
so that's what i'm doing i'm not trying
to [ __ ] kill myself with it i'm just
trying to prolong
and increase the quality of life during
these last 30 years
you know can i just say like you just
reminded me because she said about jack
lalanne and he was died in his 90s
yeah can i just say um shout out and
r.i.p
to james randy who just died he died
yeah at the age of 92.
not a bodybuilder paranormal skeptic
well a magician he was a magician yeah
and uh look up some pictures of james
randy when he was
young he was a pretty foxy [ __ ]
he was gay though he would be interested
he was gay
well he didn't come out it's sad because
he didn't come out until he was
old until he's probably like in his 80s
which i don't know why but
yeah he didn't yeah yeah he just
recently died i saw it in skeptic
magazine just like
earlier today yeah and that bums me out
because like i read a lot of his books
and i was
he's like so cantankerous and it's like
i just i loved him so
much and uh i love that he always like
called out all this [ __ ] fake uh
preachers and all his televangelists and
[ __ ]
but yeah he just passed away so um all
right so
basically like i said they found like uh
three more bottles of tylenol on
still on the shelves like little ticking
time bombs that had like poison in them
but as i said they didn't really have a
lot of leads so it's like the
investigation kind of went
fallow now let's talk about the suspects
now we're going to go back and talk
about this dude james william lewis the
dude that sent like the extortion letter
to johnson johnson demanding a million
dollars
for stopping the killings now they
actually identified him because of
fingerprints on the letter like matched
him and he had been arrested for some
other [ __ ] earlier on
now him and his wife were living in new
york city when he was arrested
now he did eventually get convicted he
didn't get convicted of
the tylenol poisonings obviously
but he did get convicted of extortion
because that is also
illegal um so he actually ended up
serving 13 years in prison on that
charge
now he got released in 2009
now the fbi and the department of
justice and everybody they did
investigate him for the poisonings
and investigators are divided over
whether they think he actually had
anything to do with it or not like it
seems like half of them say like yeah we
think he did it but we don't have enough
evidence
the other half were like no not so much
it's not like really his mo
he was just like taking you know the
opportunity to like take advantage and
get some money out of it
now in january of 2010
um lewis and his wife both gave
dna samples and fingerprints and
everything like that to the authorities
and i don't think they found anything in
particular they could use in this case
however here is something that i found
out
that i didn't actually know when i first
researched this case
but makes me a little more likely to
think that maybe he had some [ __ ] to do
with this
so james lewis he had his wife named
leanne
now they had run a tax business like
they did people's taxes
in kansas city in the early 1970s
now they were suspected
actually in another murder
now this happened they had a friend and
a client of theirs like a guy that came
uh and they did his taxes this guy
was like an older dude and he was named
raymond west
now this happened in i believe 1973 and
1974.
so they lived near this dude he was kind
of like their neighbor
and so the dude raymond west like
disappears
and his friends are like where did
raymond west go we don't really know
so the lewis's say oh he he said he was
going to the ozarks for a vacation
and he's not going to be back for a
little while right
yeah but so his other friends and family
they're not buying that
because they're like because they
because uh you know the
the lewis said he's like oh he he met
this woman and he went off
and his friends are like yeah no he's
like a lifelong bachelor he never he
would have told us if that would have
happened so they thought that was
suspicious
so they call the cops now the cops go to
the house
and they find a note stuck on the front
door that says
and the note is on the lewis's business
stationary because like i said they had
a tax business
tax business now the note says
um contact jim that'd be james lewis who
was the main suspect in the tylenol
poisonings
um call him like if you need to know
where raymond is because he told me
you know because ray's out of town and
he like is i'm taking all his messages
so the police were like okay fair enough
the door was locked so they didn't have
any cause to go in so they didn't
so a bunch of friends after that were
just kind of like dude did you really
buy that it's like that's not he
wouldn't do that he wouldn't go out of
town without telling us so the cops go
back to the house
and in the meantime it looked like
somebody else had been in there
because they were like oh well the
bedroom uh the
shades on the bedroom window were open
previously because they looked in there
and the bed was unmade and everything
but now they went back to the house and
the shades were down and like some other
[ __ ] was changed like on the outside of
the house they're like okay well
obviously somebody's been here
so the cops go in the house
and they find a note on the coffee table
that says
please don't disturb until after one
o'clock
sleeping late raymond
now the police like kind of looked
around and they're like okay i guess
everything's copacetic they didn't see
anything but again
friends were very suspicious because
they're like look
one that's not his handwriting two he
didn't go by raymond he goes by rey
he wouldn't have signed anything raymond
because that's not how that's not how he
referred to himself
so the cops leave again at this point
rey's got two friends named jack and
charles and they're like look this is
[ __ ] we're going to the house
and we're changing the locks so they go
and change the locks on the house
now at this point james lewis
the suspect he comes by the house and
he's like what the hell are you guys
doing
they're like what does it look like
we're doing we're changing the locks on
our friend's house because somebody's
obviously been in here
and they said then that james lewis like
pulled his car like over into an alley
like behind this truck and was like
watching them
until they were like done doing it which
again seems very suspicious
so at this point like the friends are
like okay they call
the cops again because they think
something weird is going on so the cops
finally go
inside the house after jack and charles
are like look we went into the house we
smelled something weird that sounded
like that smelled kind of like a dead
person
and we found what looked like dried
blood on a sheep
so please come in here and investigate
more thoroughly this time
so finally the cops come in and they
look around the house one of the cops
looks up
and sees like a foot long stain on the
ceiling
so they go up into the attic and they
find
raymond west's body
decomposed and also dismembered
somebody had cut him into pieces that's
how they got him up there
he had been gone he had been missing for
21 days for 30 for three weeks at this
point
yeah that's how they got him up there he
got him up there in pieces maybe
although there was a lot of blood like
all over the floor so they might have
done it up there
so at this point the cops are like okay
um
so james lewis like i said suspect in
the tylenol poisonings
uh was acting very suspicious uh being
like yeah he told me
like he was going out of town and you
guys should contact me in case you
needed to talk to him
or whatever so that seemed a little
fishy also
he had cashed a 5 000
check that was supposedly from raymond
west
which he later said was a business loan
which a lot of the friends were like
yeah no he was like really cheap
he would never give somebody five
thousand dollars for a business loan
much less his tax guy so suspicious
so the cops arrest james lewis
and like i said this is the early 70s
this is like 10 like
9 or 10 years before the tylenol point
things
so james lewis gets arrested now he
denied
killing raymond west what ended up
happening even though they had a lot of
physical evidence
um kind of making it seem like maybe
this dude and his wife
had like killed this guy so they could
like get all his money and they'd cut
him up and like left him in the attic
um somebody did not read james lewis his
miranda rights
like when they arrested him and they
were like some other [ __ ] so
basically he kind of got off on a
technicality
so he got released now
this is like there's a whole complicated
thing it's like i read this whole
article there's an article in the
chicago reader
called um a bitter pill written by jay
bergman
um where they kind of go way more into
like james lewis's history
and like i said i didn't know that he
was like the main suspect
in this other murder before
i you know because when i was reading
about the chicago tylenol murders and
they said well this guy was the guy that
sent the extortion letter which they
knew because of the fingerprints
but i didn't know that he was suspected
of this other horrible murder
that he he had murdered this guy that
was like his
tax client or allegedly murdered this
guy that was his attack plan and then
started to try to like cash checks like
from his account so that
makes it that seems to make it a little
more likely to me that he maybe was the
dude
that did the tylenol poisonings i'm not
really sure
branching out huh perhaps he had a
couple different routines he'd do
yeah although that's not unusual you
know
the people that put that bomb on that
dude's neck
yeah we're doing more than one thing
maybe he just thought he was [ __ ]
maybe he thought he was it's like an
early days of the gig
economy you're just kind of trying to
like make money
i don't know man but it's like so the
thing is so even though james lewis
the only thing he was convicted of in
you know
in relation to the tylenol poisonings
was extortion because they did get him
on that
but they couldn't prove that he was the
dude that actually poisoned
the pills even though the extortion
letters
were i have to say they're kind of
detailed
about how he went about poisoning the
[ __ ]
like because in the letters it talks
about how easy it was to do
i can do it in 10 minutes um i can do it
in my car
like that kind of stuff so i feel like
and so like when i first read about this
i was like well i don't know maybe he's
just like some psycho but when i read
about this other [ __ ]
that maybe he had killed like this dude
that was a client and like cash
checks like from his [ __ ] [ __ ] like
that kind of makes it more likely to me
that maybe he was
involved in this as well is that all you
got on him
i mean yeah pretty much like i said if
you really want to like because i keep
you know it's kind of outside of the
scope of the sh of the topic but if you
want to like read into like his whole
history like him and his wife and like
all the [ __ ] they got up to
there's a really good like feature
article in chicago reader
it's on their website and it's called
the bitter pill if you want to read that
it goes like really really
in depth into like that whole situation
and like the murder and everything were
there any other suspects
there were okay um yeah so that was like
the main suspect like i said
investigators are divided over whether
they know he did the extortion
now did he look like he could have been
the man with the beard in a damn video
though
it's possible okay because the thing
about it is that in the video
like the dude he had a beard and it was
like a shitty video
that kind of could have been anybody you
know what i'm saying how you could get
him today
gate recognition if you got him on video
that's what i'm saying nowadays they
would have got him
yeah but back then you know a lot of
people don't know that but your walk is
totally individual
well it is and and like i said if i know
you well i can recognize you from across
the [ __ ] room because it's like
they evidently have some ai programs
where
you could put yourself in any kind of
disguise you want and [ __ ] as far
away as you want
and that [ __ ] computer can recognize
you just by the way you walk
it's an individual signature that's
another [ __ ] spooky thing
well everything about you i'm gonna when
i go outside i'm gonna be wearing a
[ __ ] poncho a tart
i don't want you seeing me why don't you
just put a sheet over your head and
pretend
no then the [ __ ] try to kill you
because they think you're in the clan
can't do that you can just be a ghost it
doesn't have to be pointed on the top
actually depends on which clan you're
talking about the whole point of thing
that was the third clan that was the
third and
second yeah but that's what the first
clan was just
dudes in regular clothes with a [ __ ]
white
bag over their head tied around them
circles like jason
in the second half with their hats on
yeah
or like the phantom killer from the
1940s yeah that was oh that was the
1800s clan
they were just in ghost costumes but
like i said i think most people
associate the pointed hood
yeah which like i said if you walk
around with that outside nowadays you
deserve to get your [ __ ] ass kicked
but yeah so so i feel like that's kind
of like um
so he that dude's kind of like the main
suspect because like i said he did get
he served 13 years for the extortion
but they couldn't they didn't have
enough um evidence to prove that he did
the actual poisoning
although once i heard about like the
murder that happened in the 70s i was
kind of like
okay well that makes that more likely i
think but i don't really know
so one of their other suspects was this
dude named roger arnold
this is also a very interesting and a
very tragic
kind of [ __ ] that happened so this dude
roger arnold
now he gets um identified and he gets
investigated
now he eventually gets cleared however
because he had so much like media
attention surrounding him because
because this was like a [ __ ]
huge case it was like everywhere in the
media like in 1982.
so he ends up having a nervous breakdown
now he
after he had the nervous breakdown he
started blaming everything
on this dude named marty sinclair
who owned the bar where this dude went
to because apparently
how he got in trouble and how he got
investigated was because he had been at
a bar one night and he'd been drinking
and he said that he had cyanide or he
could get cyan or he said something like
that he said like something suspicious
like about the crimes or was like
talking about him a lot
and apparently somebody at the bar
turned him in to the police because he
was talking about it
so he for whatever reason blamed the bar
owner marty sinclair
for getting him into trouble and he
decided
he was gonna kill that [ __ ]
except
what ended up happening was that in the
summer of 1983
roger arnold waits outside of the place
and shoots and kills a dude that he
thinks is marty sinclair
but it's not it's a completely innocent
dude
named john stanisha who just happened to
kind of look like that guy
and got killed for absolutely no reason
at all
so uh so roger arnold even though he
apparently didn't have anything to do
with tylenol killings he actually did
get convicted of shooting
this random guy that he thought was
somebody else not like it would have
been better if he just shot the other
guy because
that dude was innocent too um so he gets
convicted in 84
and he actually ended up serving uh 15
years of a 30-year sentence that was
second degree murder
and he ended up dying in june 2008
another suspect they were looking at was
this woman
named laurie dan now in may 1988 she
apparently had gone on this weird
rampage where she was shooting random
people and also poisoning random people
which is very weird for a woman to be
doing i think this is maybe one of the
only cases of a woman doing this that
i've
ever heard of [ __ ] went crazy i mean
that's a man thing
yeah like just going around like
shooting random people
yeah that's very rare to hear of a woman
doing that so yeah but she'd had enough
i guess but yes they were bad
i guess yeah that was in winnetka
illinois um
so they thought well she's poisoned some
people maybe she's a suspect but
eventually
they thought maybe that wasn't her um
because like i said this is a very
particular
random poisonings that's a very
particular kind of
pathology you know what i mean it's kind
of like a
kind of like a bomber like a serial
bomber it is
very similar type type of profile
when when you hear when i hear of a
[ __ ] crime like that i'm gonna put it
along the side you know
i have a background in [ __ ]
um pbi which is post blast investigation
i worked for a company that trained
people
on how to [ __ ] do the forensics at
crime scenes
all right about [ __ ] after explosions
i know about the bombs and how to figure
out who made a bomb
or what the bomb was after it went off
but not too much in the psychology just
a bit of psychology
when it comes to a bomber and usually
like the main thing
one of the main traits of a [ __ ]
serial bomber
is that he under no circumstances wants
to get caught
ain't that something you don't want to
get caught that's why he's bombing
it's a lot harder to [ __ ] get caught
if you're well it is yeah
look at it this way look at how easy it
is to be
a mass shooter yeah how easy it is to be
caught if you're a mass shooter
a mass shooter is gonna get caught or
he's gonna die or both
okay they want the same thing they want
to kill a whole bunch of [ __ ] people
but the difference is is that a mass
bomber or a serial bomber
does not want to be caught that's not
part of his psychology
poisoning something on a store shelf is
real close to making a bomb it's more
terrorism yeah than serial killing you
can do it and
not get caught you're trying to evade
capture so you can continue doing it
and like you said then there's the the
psychological
[ __ ] power that you have over
over the masses yeah i mean you do this
[ __ ]
you never know when the [ __ ] is
gonna strike he's invisible
you can't catch him and he can send
messages forever to the cops
and be heard that's what it seems like
but did this guy ever try to communicate
no not that i'm aware of other than
unless it was james lewis
in which case he sent that extortion
letter which they caught him for
if he was the one that actually poisoned
the pills
which he may have been then he
communicated in that way
by trying to get a million dollars out
of johnson and johnson for stopping
poisoning their [ __ ] you see i'm not
really buying that
i don't know i'm just saying i think
that like me finding out that he had
actually been involved like been a
suspect
in another murder like 10 years prior
that makes him like maybe more likely
because he actually maybe
possibly allegedly did kill it and it
was only tylenol how many different
batches of tylenol did he poison
well it was um the thing about it is
that they found
as far as i know i think they found
excuse me they found like um
six to eight different bottles like in
different stores so it was somebody that
was going to different stores they were
all like around chicago though like
in that area and it was tylenol yeah so
extra strength tylenol extra strength
tylenol yeah
all of them now when he bought the extra
strength tylenol
to poison did he buy it all at once do
they know that
well no because it was from different
stores from different stores
so i don't know if he well because
here's the thing so for some reason he
might have either bought them
he might have stolen them he might have
bought or stolen them from one store
taken them to his car or to his house
poisoned them
because like i said all you had to do
was pull the capsule apart and put cyan
in there put the capsule back together
put it back in the bottle and no one
would know any difference because there
was no
packaging and then you would just go
back in the store and sneak it under the
what's up is that it's all tylenol
yeah i would think
that it'd be more although maybe not
because if you did
random items
possibly you'd be possibly
you wouldn't be labeled as
the same person well because it wouldn't
be
a signature right maybe he wanted the
signature
you see here's the deal i don't really
think
that he had anything against the tile at
all company
no that was true something that that's
just what that's just what he
that's just what he used he wanted
notoriety and he must have
wanted to give some kind of a message
but they never really got it i don't
think it was money
it was power that's what he wanted
he wanted to say something
in a way a serial killer wants to say
something when they kill a person you
know i mean they kind of look kind of
like the zodiac
remember the zodiac yeah i picture him
being a guy kind of like the zodiac
but for some reason or another they
never got any communication from it
maybe he killed himself i kind of feel
like this is
like i said it's this is more like a
terrorist kind of mindset than a serial
killer kind of
because serial killers generally not
always but like serial killers
they're kind of into the kill it's more
of a sexual or like a sensual kind of
thing
whereas i feel like this one was more
like
he was getting off on that damn point on
causing
random like i'll just kill random people
nobody
will know who it will be so everyone
will be afraid so it was more like a
terroristic getting off on the
motive he's getting off on the fact that
he's not there
he's doing this [ __ ] remotely without
any effort
yeah you know what i mean he's not
getting off on that and apparently copy
you with the [ __ ] knife plunging you
and apparently well and i think that he
got off too
like you know i don't know i'm not that
he sees himself as a criminal mastermind
yeah i definitely think that but i i
think that he's thinking look how
easy it is to disrupt the entire like
operation of like look look how easy it
is for me to like kill randomly look how
easy it is for me to like make everyone
in the country afraid
yeah you know look how easy it is for me
to get millions of dollars with a
product like recalled
like caused this big [ __ ] terror like
across the country look how easy that is
i think that's i think what he
originally wanted was to do something
kind of like
the zodiac where he would give a message
and be able to communicate
or something kind of like dennis raider
where he would give a message and talk
to the cops and communicate
because that's part of their gloating
yeah that boosts their
ego talking the cops are talking to me
because i'm a criminal mastermind
i'm the [ __ ] joker yeah that's
basically what you're dealing with yeah
they all think that but for some reason
other he stopped
either either it wasn't satisfying he
stopped
and he you know what i mean it it it
itched
it it scratched the itch so he's like
okay that wasn't very satisfying and he
stopped
or he killed himself or it could be that
it was james lewis and he stopped
because he got put in prison for the
extortion
i don't see this as a extortion i don't
think he was trying to extort
maybe maybe well yeah but maybe but
maybe it could be both things like maybe
it could have been like he got off on
doing that and then he's like hey i'm
gonna make a million bucks out of this
also like on top of it
maybe but i kind of
just off the top of my head what i've
imagined the kind of guy that does this
he doesn't want money he wants to talk
he doesn't want to get
caught he wants to be heard and he wants
to talk
he wants the attention he wants to gloat
yeah but that didn't happen these are
people
that kind of client that kind of crime
fits that kind of personality
even even the the una bomber
well that's what i was going to talk
about next because the unabomber was
also considered a suspect
in this series yeah because the una
bomber like
he likes to kill remotely yeah and then
be heard
and yeah and kind of gloat over the fact
that i have the power to kill a person
remotely you better [ __ ] listen to
what i got to say yeah
well that's kind of why because his mo
was very similar
um the fbi did look into ted kaczynski
the unabomber in case you guys didn't
know
um as a suspect in the tylenol murders
and in an actual fact in 2011 they asked
for a dna sample from him
but now ted kaczynski has denied he's
like i never had anything to do with
potassium cyanide i never did that
um but some people have pointed out
they're like look
um the weird thing about it is that even
though
so ted kaczynski's parents lived in
lombard illinois
in 1982 which was like right in the
middle
of where all the poisonings took place
also which i think is something uh again
that a lot of people don't know
there was another tylenol poisoning of
like one guy
in another city that was like halfway
between
chicago and the unabomber's
cabin in montana that happened like a
little bit later
so they were i mean the fbi were looking
into it because they're like this is a
very similar thing to like you said like
a male bomber this is like a
you know somebody that enjoys like
killing people like remotely
like not being there and having that
kind of power over them
so they did look into they also looked
into
and this seems like kind of a reach but
maybe not
um that ted kaczynski seemed to have
this weird
obsession with the word
wood and like wood adjacent kind of
terms
like his wood as in tree wood yeah yeah
okay
um so like his one of his aliases
was like the last name was wood and like
all of his
like the fake addresses he would use
like on the um like the bombs that he
would send
like where like wood lawn avenue like
wood
yeah it was like that kind of thing and
interestingly
like both the dudes that founded johnson
and johnson their middle name was wood
which some people have pointed out as
like maybe that was kind of a thing like
because he had like some weird kind of
well ted was ted was a certain kind of
guy
crazy and i don't think he did this he
was crazy but the guy was [ __ ] highly
educated where do you ever think
i think he went to harvard berkeley
berkeley zoda was berkeley he was a
mathematician
yeah and um there's some people that say
that he was kinda
he had been involved in some of those
cia um
lsd experiments and some of those mk
ultra experiments that he actually
volunteered for all that
so maybe that had something to do with
it but from what i remember of ted
kaczynski's [ __ ] manifesto
a lot of the [ __ ] that he said in that
wasn't stupid
he was talking about the rise of a.i and
all kinds of stuff that's happening now
and uh [ __ ] that was happening to the
ecology
of the earth he was a [ __ ]
environmentalist really he was an
environmental terrorist that was his
main thing
and he was going after the heads of
industry that they were you know
destroying the earth
but what was weird is that from what i
remember correctly some of you guys
maybe in the audience might correct me
i thought he was if i remember correctly
been a long time since i read that [ __ ]
i think he was talking about the rise of
ai
ai algorithms and [ __ ] like a
technocracy
which that is kind of happening through
the internet
it was all pre-internet that he was
talking about that humans would be
controlled by algorithms and [ __ ]
that they'd be controlled
by seeking out the weaknesses in their
psychology and they'd be could be showed
certain things by ai
which would uh make them easier to
control
that's just i i haven't thought of that
dude in years that was just based on
memory
so there was something to the guy he was
intelligent
yeah he wasn't a dummy sure it's just i
think that's a little bit of an
overreaction he was saying this is the
only way he could
fight the rising technocracy and threat
of ai
and industrialism and that he was going
to do this
that's why he refused i mean he refused
to say that he was insane
they tried to get him to do it to be
honest it's it's sad because people that
are
i mean he was like obviously highly
intelligent but
sometimes people that are that highly
intelligent sometimes they have
um like schizophrenic type of [ __ ]
let me mention something else about
intelligence you know i was in the
direct sale business and i did notice
that
i [ __ ] sold in wellesley
massachusetts which is that was the
[ __ ]
best sales territory the [ __ ] company
i worked for could could
possibly be in it was the top top
top income bracket of the united states
man [ __ ] wellesley college that's where
it's where hillary clinton went was
right across the street from my [ __ ]
office in wellesley all of the [ __ ]
founding
families you know the [ __ ]
rockefellers and the vanderbilts and
[ __ ]
came from that area it was nothing but
mansions
i would sell [ __ ] central [ __ ]
vacuum cleaner systems and [ __ ]
floor care and [ __ ] carpet shampoo
[ __ ] equipment
to these rich people and i found
that the more intelligent
and the more wealthy a person was
the easier it was to sell things to them
because they had imaginations that sales
techniques could work on
they had that you could play on their
self-interest
and they were agreeable
you could use their politeness against
them all right
through robert l shook's hardball sales
techniques
which you guys could look those up those
worked real well on
very intelligent rich people they did
not work well
on [ __ ] dumb people that was like
trying to sell to a shark
all right and sharks don't have any
intelligence and sharks won't buy
anything
jenny and i sometimes get into it
sometimes off the
out of the show the more educated and
the more
intelligent a person is in these
universities and stuff and
when they get out usually the more apt
they are to believe in things that are
[ __ ]
not true because they don't really have
a street wisdom
and and their intelligence you can
dazzle their intelligence and get them
to believe in the things that aren't
going to happen
it's like a strength and a weakness in
the same time because this person can
imagine something that might happen
because it should but at the same time
you as an average
person or a slightly above aspect but
know that it's a pipe dream
it just seems that and and i don't know
how i got on this [ __ ]
situation it had to do with this [ __ ]
bomber i'm drunk and i went down to
[ __ ] fly back
but um i think that's what happened to
ted kaczynski
ted that's what it was is it ted
kaczynski was very intelligent and he
let his imagination run away with him
that's what i think happened to him well
i don't even know if it's that i think
that
people that are like stupid intelligent
like i'm just
i'm talking about like really really
like way above average human
intelligence
i think that kind of genetically goes
hand in hand
with particular types of mental
illness yeah um because i mean
in my experience and in uh all science
and you know poll numbers and everything
experience
generally the more educated you are the
less likely you are to fall for stupid
[ __ ]
um so take that as as
as you will but but i'm just saying that
like sometimes
people that that are like really really
really super intelligent sometimes that
goes like all the way around and becomes
like
not stupid necessarily but where to a
point where they get
they're not really like in reality
anymore because they're not like
relating to like regular people anymore
yeah you know what i'm saying
so it is kind of like a um a handicap in
a way yeah
that's what i saw but that's like a
that's like people that are like
ridiculous intelligent yeah
that's what i saw working in in
wellesley i'd run across some people
that were in the
what ended up being in the tech industry
and
very poor social skills very weird
you know what i mean and like almost
autistic
like high-functioning autistic people um
yeah victor said most of the people
sharing conspiracy theories on my
facebook are dumb as [ __ ]
i will agree yeah i will agree yeah well
yeah
[Laughter]
just didn't have anything to do with
conspiracy theories though no but i'm
just saying that like i do feel like
what consider kazinski was talking about
was not a conspiracy theory he was
talking about the direction in which
civilization was going towards because
of the technology he didn't like it
he thought it was anti-human right but
it's like so
but the thing about it is that you can
be right about some things
and still be nuts you know what i'm
saying
yeah in a stop clock is right twice a
day
type of way yeah but that's not what
that's not what ted was
ted was intelligent didn't like what was
happening and he was taking
he it was a one-man war to try to stop
it that's what he was trying to do
yeah but he went about it in the
stupidest way possible
so he obviously well he killed a bunch
of people before he caught him
yeah but they still caught him they
still come and his own brother turned
him in
yeah but he was but he was willing to
die for that [ __ ] and
he had he was not bullshitting i mean
the dude lived in a [ __ ] cabin
without any electricity
yeah i mean he didn't
he lived like an american indian sure
okay so he was serious about what he was
saying
he just believed and
like i said before early on like like
obi-wan kenobi said
many of the things we believe in but
depend upon a certain point of view
the japanese ultra nationalists believed
in
the japan that they envisioned so much
that they threw their airplanes on the
decks
of [ __ ] american [ __ ] aircraft
carriers
dying in the flames were they stupid or
crazy
no not at all they were trying to defend
the japanese homeland and their families
back in the [ __ ] homeland
for what they believed in so i
understand civilians get wrapped up in
that
but were they right yeah they were right
they were right well from their
perspective from their point of view
they were right
but but that's the thing everybody has
their own
right reasons for doing something right
but like if you're
exit let me take a little bit further
yeah he was right for throwing the plane
onto the american aircraft carrier
but had he waited all that [ __ ] would
have worked out eventually anyway but
they didn't know
you know what i mean yeah because
japan for a while dominated the [ __ ]
exports
their companies kicked ass you know with
cars and technology
so in a way their fears were a little
bit overblown
but they didn't know and that's just
that's the story of history
ted kaczynski i'm not even sure that
dude is wrong
what he believed you know he might be
right what he was talking about from
what i remember that might actually come
true
but that might take centuries when he's
talking about like blowing up innocent
people that's like
he didn't he said they weren't innocent
because they owned these industries that
were doing all right i gotcha but yeah
so
it all depends on your certain point the
thing about it is that same
thing those animal rights activists do
yeah but when they attack
furriers or when they're attacking the
same thing humans
are imperfect we don't know what's going
to happen in the future
you don't know like all of the
circumstances that are going to come
out come about in the future it's like
you taking out one innocent person now
it might seem like a good idea
like hey let's kill this person and then
i'll solve everything
but it's like you don't know what is
going to happen
in the wake of that nobody knows right
because we're just humans and we're
right i counter we're just meat puppets
i understand that but i counter what
you're saying this way
the same argument could be had of well
maybe we shouldn't have done
anything to stop the nazis because we
didn't know the future
maybe after the holocaust a good thing
would have happened
well no because that's another way but
you already know
what they were doing you already know
what they were no
we we declared war on them and started
fighting them before we knew about the
holocaust anybody that has
ideological views that are like hey
these types of people are bound we just
like wipe them all out you should just
like yeah no that's not
that's not acceptable not acceptable
and i'm just saying but i'm just saying
that an individual person
like ted kaczynski say i just feel like
you don't have enough
you just don't have enough foreknowledge
even if you're right about some [ __ ]
even if he was
right about you know the technocracy or
whatever even if he was right about that
taking out the people that he took out
you don't know if those people had any
effect on what he was even talking about
even who's right
you know what i mean he's just one dude
he doesn't know
it's just like it's just like military
campaigns he
did the same thing militaries do okay
they don't know either
when they target an enemy or an enemy
leader
or an enemy [ __ ] fuel depot they
don't know either
it's an ongoing campaign all right
so i understand it it's somebody trying
to
sure i mean you can only operate on like
what knowledge you have at the moment i
get that which
you know do i agree with it would i have
done it no
no but you try to put yourself in the
place of a crazy [ __ ] and see
things the way they're trying to see it
if not you will never understand it and
it has to do with in human nature to be
able to do that
helps you resonate with humans and their
nature of what they are
never try to make a human being more
than what they are
where an animalistic species where are
animals
right but that's not something to aspire
to either you shouldn't
want to like act like a [ __ ] animal
like no insult to animals
nobody's saying that it's just things
are limited
well sure i know that people act in
their own interest they try to [ __ ]
sure
i know they try to stop things that they
think are bad they try to
create things that they think are good
and no one agrees on any of this [ __ ] so
you're well like i said
conflict the problem is yeah that no one
has that much foresight because you
don't know
i mean there's like seven billion of us
or how many of us that are on the earth
like in addition to all the other
animals in addition to all the other
like [ __ ] that we can't control
you know happening um i think i was kind
of gifted
with being [ __ ] up being able to
[ __ ] understand
to try to put myself in the shoes
of even people that are kind of [ __ ]
up you know what i mean
i know when some somebody's wrong but i
can see the error
some of their errors you know what i
mean
i sometimes i do like when they're
killing children and [ __ ] i'm like
[ __ ] you gotta die
you know but i kind of understand more
of these guys like kaz
kozinski he thinks he's doing the right
thing
even if he's gonna he was very
intelligent he might be like
well yeah maybe these guys that i'm
striking
taking them out won't stop this but it
will
cause public awareness to [ __ ] you
know
like a pr campaign yeah but all it did
was cause public awareness that ted
kaczynski is a wacko
yeah good job yeah but it was a long
time ago
had that happen now with the internet
with a greater understanding who knows
you might have had
say like antifa or blm going yeah yeah
he's right
it might have been very different no i
don't think that would have happened
i think everybody would have still
thought he was a wacko just more you
would have more people saying is a wacko
and also you would have like a
contingent of like people going yeah
like
just like all those [ __ ] idiots that
think like elliot roger
is a [ __ ] hero who's elliot roger
that dude that like shot up all those
women because no one would date him oh
that dude
yeah you know he's a hero
they segment that's got to be trolling
4chan that's got to be no he's got like
a whole thing
he's got a whole fan club well okay oh
what's his name vampire killer the
[ __ ] my old [ __ ] boss
who rod farrell rob farrell yeah i saw
i worked for the [ __ ] woman who
defended rob farrell for a little while
[ __ ] vampire killer i saw his [ __ ]
case files and [ __ ] early on during
part of his incarceration
some people think raw ferals are [ __ ]
there's no one so [ __ ] up
that's right is [ __ ] up he's [ __ ]
crazy that someone won't
laud him for whatever reason yeah
because people are
well there's always gonna be a segment
because people are messed up
people are messed up yeah people are
messed up and stupid
but yeah so that's always going to
happen but so
now before we get off on this whole
tangent like ted kaczynski
i can understand why the fbi would look
at him
for these types of murders because it
was a similar mo like i said it was like
random kind of [ __ ]
but i don't know is it because is it
necessarily random because ted kaczynski
did seem to like
target particular people even though he
worked from a distance
this seemed to be like i'm just gonna
put poison on the shelves and i don't
care who takes it
so this seemed more like even more like
a terroristic type of act because he
didn't really care who took the tylenol
he just wanted to engender fear in the
populace
you know what i'm saying he didn't
really particularly care who we took out
on the way out
wasn't targeted so i don't necessarily
think that ted kaczynski had anything to
do with this although i can see why the
fbi would
uh examine him like on those counts
now interestingly because
johnson and johnson were so
uh on the ball with this cause like i
said only
a couple of days after the murders
um they were pretty much on it and they
were just like look we're gonna like
take all the [ __ ] off the shelves they
immediately like stopped all advertising
they did like pretty much
everything they could do to safeguard
the public you know
within reason and so it does seem like
about like you know their shares dropped
to like what eight percent of the market
like before that they had been i believe
35
of the market so during this crisis
dropped to 8 however about a year later
they were back up to thank you hayden oh
my goodness thank you
very very much that's awesome they were
pretty much back
up to like the top uh of the market
again
thanks bro just because the public
perceive them is like
you know acting immediately in the
public interest and like immediately
taking [ __ ] off the shelves and like
acting like prevent further
damage so they seem to do a good job pr
wise in you know mitigating the damage
from this so they did actually i mean
a lesser company if you'd reacted wrong
i mean would have been put
out of business by this kind of [ __ ]
right because everybody would be
like terrified to take your [ __ ] so the
fact that that didn't happen
is kind of a credit and i believe i'm
not sure but i believe that they're
still like teaching this kind of [ __ ] in
business schools as to like
when a crisis happens with your company
like this is how you react
so because so they seem to do the right
thing now
most people say that however there have
been some books out lately that
um there was one called the tylenol
mafia it was self-published
you know i'm not [ __ ] on that but
i'm just like mentioning it um
but that said that maybe
this what are you doing don't worry
about it oh you're met well you're okay
okay
you're messing up my stuff he's like i
don't know what you're doing you're
pushing my [ __ ]
um that mentioned that maybe
this was a johnson johnson employee and
they were like covering it up or somehow
like this happened at the manufacturing
level or at the factory or something and
they were like covering it up because
they didn't want to like say
and so they were like attributing it to
some random psycho because they don't
want to get in trouble or whatever but i
don't know if i really buy that
because like i said because of the way
that cyanide reacts with the
capsules that it that after 48 72 hours
it would have like eaten the capsules
away and they didn't really find that
so i feel like the [ __ ] was put into the
capsules like
very very shortly before they found the
[ __ ] on the shelves
which leads me to believe that it was
not put in there in the factories you
know what i'm saying
so as i said now this song this case has
not been solved they never did find the
person that did any of this
sadly um well okay
before that happily like i said this led
to
a you know an industry-wide change
this was the the start of like caplets
instead of capsules
this was the start of all the [ __ ] uh
packaging that you see nowadays
like the [ __ ] the [ __ ] around the
caps the foil all that stuff
um that came into being like they now
they have like three four levels of like
[ __ ] you have to go through so
packages can't be adulterated so this
was the start of all that
um and as i said they passed a law that
made uh product tampering like a federal
offense so you can get like in a lot
more trouble
um for doing this kind of [ __ ] now sadly
though
um there were of course because people
suck
um copycat attacks
after this case because this was a
massive media case all over the country
so there were a whole bunch of copycat
cases that took place afterward
and in fact even though everybody talks
about the seven
tylenol cases there were also in 1986
like a few years afterward um there were
three people
killed in uh 1986 after
like some gelatin capsules there had
been
uh adulterated with poison um also there
was a woman who died in yonkers new york
after taking an extra strength tylenol
capsule that was also laced with cyanide
which was apparently not related to this
uh initial
case now here's another case
that this was actually this is
interesting because this was the first
case that was prosecuted under these new
laws that came about because of the
tylenol poisonings where they
you know made product tampering a
federal offense
so this happened in washington state now
this was not
tylenol capsules it was excedrin
capsules
now this was the deaths of susan snow
and bruce nichol now they both took
excedrin
and they both died also from cyanide
poisoning
and it ended up so what ends up
happening is that
for a time they thought that
this was another case where it was some
random psychopath
like putting [ __ ] into the excedrin
capsules
like a copycat only they found out later
as they did the investigation that it
was
actually bruce nicholl one of the
victims it was his wife
stella had put cyanide and some [ __ ]
from like some algaecide from like her
fish tanks because she did like she
she was like a fish tank obvious she put
that in his excedrin capsules and
killed him and this other woman
and um she was trying to get his
insurance payout
she got like almost 200 000 from that
but it took them a long time to figure
that out because like i said this whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] had happened with the
tylenol [ __ ]
so and she was like right up there at
the front she's like oh i'm gonna sue
this the excedrin company or whoever the
[ __ ] made excedrin
i'm gonna sue them because like all
their [ __ ] pills are adulterated and
killed my husband and it killed this
other people
and then they turned out like as the
investigation went on that she [ __ ]
did that [ __ ]
damn because the bottle that killed
him and the bottle that killed this
other woman susan snow
they were both like from the same lot
and it was like in her
house so they're like the chances of
this being two different bottles
very slim so they found out that it was
uh that it was her that she had done
yeah that's
that that's yeah some of the comments
jason's bringing up a good thing
maybe she killed her husband to make it
look random
she did yeah well she did yeah that's
kind of what because her whole thing
like maybe she killed the other people
stella nickel no no no this is a
different case this was in washington
state okay all right
this happened like um like three or four
years later
okay but that i think that's where she
got the idea because i think
she wanted to bump off her husband to
get the insurance
but she wanted to make it look like that
kind of guy that's what i'm saying
because at first they thought that it
was the same thing but it took them a
while to like figure out that it was her
yeah
because here's the thing about her
stella nickel is her name you can look
her up on wikipedia
now she was kind of like even from a
very early age
she was like super into like doing fraud
and all that kind of [ __ ] she did she
did all kind of [ __ ]
and she also had like some uh some
violent kind of crimes too
like she'd like beat her kids and she
didn't but she did other
[ __ ] too fraud forgery that type of [ __ ]
so
she meets her husband and at first her
and her husband get along really well
like they're both drunks and she's like
into it
but he like goes to aaa and stops
drinking and that pisses her off
because apparently she really likes
drinking and she doesn't want to be with
somebody that's sober
and so that like makes her really mad
and apparently she gets an idea
that she's gonna bump him off yeah you
know what i mean
now so what so he comes home with a
headache one day takes some excedrin
and then he collapsed and then died
now they didn't think anything of it at
the time they thought that maybe it was
like
just he had cardiac arrest or he had
because he had emphysema and it's like
maybe it was that
and then um but then this other woman
dies sue snow
who is like uh she's like a bank manager
or something like that
and so then they find out that the same
poison that killed her had killed him
and then they found that poison
at their house you know what i mean at
the nickel house
so they figured out that it was the same
and also that
it didn't help too that it wasn't just
the cyanide but it was also the
algaecide
and they figured out that the algaecide
was from like that because you used it
like to kill algae in your fish tanks
and that they figured out that susan
nickel had bought it at like a fish
store
and that she had put it in there too i
guess for good measure i don't know
not a master criminal obviously but yeah
so she got a
she eventually got caught she got
arrested i think she was in
she's not supposed to get out until like
20 40. i'm sure she'll be dead by then
she got like a 90 or something oh yeah
she did
[Laughter]
but yeah so but she did definitely try
to like make it look like
all right and like i said she also like
tried to sue the excedrin company like
she was making it seem like it happened
at the manufacturing level or whatever
so she did like
willingly like look it like make it look
like that kind of [ __ ]
all right patrick blair says ted
kaczynski's bombings were targeted and
ideological
yeah they weren't random like the tying
off stuff that's kind of yeah it makes
no sense that he was involved
that's kind of what i'm yeah i'm
thinking i honestly i'm kind of leaning
toward it being the extortion guy
just because once i found out that he
had probably
allegedly like murdered another dude
mark said q anon is real
okay he's being sarcastic
q anon i think is an it's a phenomenon
i think that was a 4chan or 8-chan group
that decided they were going to think of
the stupidest conspiracy theater
they could think of that someone would
actually believe i don't believe so
i believe i believe that's what i think
i don't believe so i believe it was
kind of like and then people actually
believed it i think
they just kept it i think it was kind of
like a group of people that were
trying to pick together a bunch of
different news sources to make a [ __ ]
a picture of something yeah yeah see
victor says living on his eight chance
roles that's
yeah yeah but i also think it has just
because somebody says it doesn't mean
it's real
i think it was crowd-sourced news
narrative
that's what i think it was is it
accurate
i don't know man the only thing that
i've seen from is they're saying it's a
[ __ ] bunch of satanic pedophiles
but pedophilia keeps [ __ ] popping up
over and over again
and i remember all right you [ __ ] can
say whatever the [ __ ] you want
i remember back in the 90s they had a
[ __ ] senate hearing
where a bunch of girls were put up i
think of a senate hearing or hearing
before the house
a bunch of girls that came out of the
um foster home system
said that they were sent to it was like
something out of satanic panic
that they were sent to
doctors places and psychologists and
that they were
uh kept in cages and molested and that
they forced multiple personalities into
them
in an attempt to turn them into sex
operatives
and that [ __ ] was like in the 80s and
90s early 90s
and underage sex operatives does seem to
be a theme
in intelligence communities going back
to nazi germany
the nazis knew about that they were
taking kids
this is see this is some [ __ ] civilians
don't understand
intelligence agencies will do whatever
they're above the law
they're criminal organizations
in nazi germany they were taking kids
nazi doctors and there was a lot of
[ __ ] a lot of people in the nazi
party were doctors they noticed in their
version of the [ __ ]
um uh uh what do you call it
orphanages that there was a bunch of
[ __ ] multiple personality kids
they found out that sexual abuse caused
multiple personalities
and somehow during the nazis during that
operation paper clip that got taken into
the [ __ ] you know what i mean
the rocket science and [ __ ] some of them
were actually
taken into the cia about mind control
and they were in that mk ultra pro
program they were trying to evidently
this is rumored
at this point that they were trying to
induce multiple personality disorder in
kids
to turn them into spies and assassins
but evidently they found out you could
also use it as dirt on people to control
them
in the same way back in the old days you
could use being gay
to control somebody but you can't use
that anymore
but being a pedophile you that that's
holding serious dirt over
somebody it makes sense to me based in
my [ __ ] knowledge that maybe in
intelligence agents
agencies would be interested in
underage sex operatives and then all of
a sudden
boom child island man appears
epstein telling you man
shit's gonna come out and your heads are
gonna [ __ ] spin
they're more sophisticated and more evil
than you think they are
they just are alex says satanic rituals
like that are real i was the victim of a
cult that flushed me down a daycare
toilet at the time [ __ ] you keep
talking did you
did you meet chuck norris as well [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was
and then did you fly away
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] was obviously [ __ ] you know
i mean trying to get crazy [ __ ]
statements out of kids but no man
intelligence agencies could do some
[ __ ] weird ass [ __ ] if you have if
you can get your hands on kids
that don't have parents you could do
it and you know have all this [ __ ]
knowledge like [ __ ] yeah we molest
them we'll turn them into multiples
and program them into sex operatives so
we can
get people to have sex with them on tape
and control them or assassinate people
that be a powerful weapon this that's
how crazy
some of those intelligence agencies are
that's what it's about it's like
something like a
out of a gang anyway i'm just not sure
how effective that is because
it may not be effective but quote
unquote multiple personality disorder
which they now call dissociative
identity disorder
is very very rare and some people
actually
um question whether it exists exist i
understand that but what they would have
found out
through that program eventually is that
all you have to do is to get a
[ __ ] on tape having sex with a
kid and you got him
you can get him to do whatever you
wanted and that's what the child island
doesn't have sex with kids don't have
sex with kids
[ __ ] what's his name told those
hollywood those hollywood people stop
[ __ ] kids and he was was he joking we
don't know
stop having sex with kids that's the
[ __ ] rumor
and the chuck and those people some of
those people were on the flight logs to
the child
island child island man was [ __ ] a
real man
and just gizzling maxwell had cia
[ __ ] connections i think
chad island man was a cia operative i
think he was cia
that's why he didn't go down for that
[ __ ] he did here in florida
it sounds [ __ ] crazy but they are
crazy
that's the thing you gotta understand
intelligence agencies are
[ __ ] crazy all right
[Laughter]
all right you deny if you want until
those [ __ ] [ __ ]
got you on tape [ __ ] them little kids
no one's gonna get me on tape [ __ ]
little kids
why would they get me [ __ ] little
kids they got some dudes they got a lot
of dudes on tape [ __ ] little kids
everything that got them out of that
island um
i'm not a dude yeah and i don't [ __ ]
little kids so why would i be on tape do
it
[ __ ] any of those things okay filthy
gardener says you can tell this chick is
tired of hearing his [ __ ] stories
[ __ ] you talking sporty like that makes
me just think that you're trying to ride
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
sexy [ __ ] are you talking
sporting to me like that on our on our
own show
and then you go let's see what else is
going on
talking about the in-cell idol the guy
that you're talking about yeah elliot
roger
i told you man he has a whole fan club
it's disturbing
i don't know how you didn't know about
that but it's very disturbing
because yeah people they're like yeah
[ __ ] won't sleep with me so i'm gonna
go
just kill a bunch of random girls
because that's how it works i guess i
don't know sheila says i heard the
orphans made the best operatives that's
what this that's
what the rumor is but we won't know
until
more information is out
by the look on her face i don't think
jenny's buying your theory tom
look alex jenny's a normal woman
she lived a normal [ __ ] life i didn't
i know these [ __ ] are crazy
there's [ __ ] that i [ __ ] was involved
in
in the military and also in the [ __ ]
contracting world
some of it she knows and some of it she
knows is true and also
my family connections you know my family
his state department
and other federal agencies and stuff
weird [ __ ] happens we they do weird [ __ ]
well sure i know that
but i'm just like for
i you know i'm just like show me the
evidence that's all yeah well here's
it's like look i write about true crime
i know about all this kind of [ __ ]
i know how crazy people are i know the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] people get up to i know he thinks
i'm naive and all this other [ __ ] but
it's i'm not i know
i know what [ __ ] get like remember that
remember that but
i'm also aware that people make up
a bunch of stupid [ __ ] also so i'm very
reluctant
it's just like believing [ __ ] the whole
world
someone says the whole mk ultra mind
control program
we're very lucky to have just that
there's evidently
a lot more to that that we don't have
that evidently was just a small part of
it
that right there gives you an idea of
what it was you were dealing with back
then who knows what it is now i mean
look us army man [ __ ] we were
guarding
[ __ ] poppy fields in afghanistan
why drugs are [ __ ] cia black budget
money
that's why do you think where do you
think black black mud budget money comes
from
what we know but that's not weird we
know it comes from drugs but then let me
ask you this
does it come from human trafficking have
they included that too
uh yeah they probably would they
probably would
okay i think that's that's in their
psychological profile
now the guys at the top if they're
already okaying [ __ ] human
trafficking are they taking
slaves themselves well if you look at
[ __ ]
i think they probably might be i'd like
to we have to
know more we just have to know more
there's a lot of missing people
and you would think maybe state state
level powers wouldn't would be involved
in that but that's not even the main
thing i think there's a lot more to it
than that
i don't want to get in trouble i don't
want to say anymore because i can i just
i just
i i think it will eventually come out
i think it'll eventually come out it's
easy to control people with dirt
that's the more dirt you have on someone
that
the more control you have so if you're
going to let somebody in on us
on some contracts or a good deal you got
to get dirt on them before you let them
join the gang or you won't be able to
trust them
and that's the way an organized crime
syndicates at work
you kill someone in order to get in and
they got dirt on you and then all of a
sudden you can trust that person they're
co-conspiracies
it makes more sense to me that we're
dealing with basically something kind of
like ancient
rome that that's really what
the united states is and they're
doing bad [ __ ] and it's like a mafia
but if you didn't do bad [ __ ] in the
first place you wouldn't have to worry
about it but if you didn't do the bad
[ __ ] you wouldn't get into the club
i don't want to be in that club that's
the club that they're in i don't want to
be in that that's the way i'm seeing it
because they
want that dirt or they want to all can
look all through my history and like
yeah well
not gonna find nothing even if you did
find something we are i'm not gonna get
upset about it
we are not living in a fish tank
we are living in a shark tank and if you
look up it's nothing but sharks
you can't get to that level without
being bad
you can't accrue that amount of money in
power without being bad
i've never seen it in history or any
historical documents going back to the
roman era
of where good people made money only bad
people make money and gain power
that's why that seems to be the rule
thank you very much
thank you very much whenever i start
talking crazy the money starts rolling
in
yes it is true that's what i suspect we
can't prove it yet but that's what i
think it is
well i don't think that's news though i
mean obviously like people on the top
are shitty
i mean obviously everybody's known that
i just think they're shittier than you
think they are
that's what they can't be shittier than
i think they're shittier they can't be
shittier though i think they're
basically organized criminals because
yeah but like maybe that's why i don't
get upset because i already like have a
dimmer view of them
you know what i mean i already think
they're human garbage so i don't really
like but you know i'm not bothered i'm
just like yeah it stands to reason
drug trafficking human trafficking and
lying
cheating murder assassination there's
too many dead people connecting like i
said
connecting to too many powerful people
that's
yeah all i'm saying is that like i
already have like i said i already have
a dim view of people at the top
i've i've always had that um you know i
grew up poor so it's like i
i've always had a dim view of rich
people whatever they get up to i'm sure
they're getting up to that and worse
um so that doesn't surprise me i'm just
saying
that for evidence of like a a vast
conspiracy type of thing
like some of the people like i said i'm
not a big conspiracy theory person for
some of these vast conspiracies to work
you have to have like thousands of
people that have to be in on it blah
blah it's like i feel like the bigger
the conspiracy
the less likely it is to be true because
there's too many people that have to
keep quiet
and there's not enough evidence for it
that's all i'm saying i'm not saying
that conspiracies don't exist
or that rich people don't suck because
they do i'm not saying that i'm just
saying that
some of the [ __ ] that people come up
with is far-fetched or they don't have
evidence
that's all i'm saying i'm not saying
it's a conspiracy i'm saying it's a
lifestyle
i think that's just how they are it's
not a conspiracy well that's uh i'm not
arguing with that
because like i said they suck i think
that's their normal way of being and
it's
been that way for probably centuries
probably a couple hundred years
the thing about it is just that we're
finding out about it now no everybody's
always known about that
but i've been so i don't think so i
think where have you been i think some
people believe
that the powers that [ __ ] ran the
show cared about
americans american people wanted to win
only idiots only idiots believed that
no one did no one cares i thought they
kind of cared no they don't
no i don't know why they're kind of i
don't know why they're shocking to you i
don't know
more like kind of more like uh monarchs
from the middle ages
that's what i mean well like i said
maybe because i grew up as like a broke
dick
[ __ ] yeah you were yeah you were poor
so yeah
i believed in the lies no okay no i
never did
so it's like so oh rich people suck oh
film at 11.
that's it's like no shock to me and like
anything you can tell me about like how
they behave
the more money you have the more [ __ ]
you can get away with and you're not
gonna get caught so of course they're
gonna get away with it because they're
horrible horrible people
so that is not shocking to me to me it's
like not a conspiracy
it's not like a big revelation it's not
anything it's just like
i'm like of course that's what they
would do because that's what they would
do
they have the money and they get it this
is a classic spock versus kirk moment on
the show
exactly exactly she is spock and i'm
kirk
but i'm not surprised by it you seem
like you to be constantly surprised by
it and i do not understand yeah
tom go on a spiel okay
i don't it's not so much that i'm
surprised by like i'm just surprised why
you think it's like revelatory because
yeah zach saying he just saw the [ __ ]
videos about mk ultra i thought
everybody knew like how badly everyone
at the top sucked i just thought that
was like common knowledge so it's like i
don't really know why you're like
shocked by it
okay go ahead jenny go ahead go to the
show i'm just saying well i was mostly
done it's like it's just kind of like i
was acting you know what i was actually
going to talk about it says tom and
jenny sound like me and my hubby
and zach says i think of them like
specter zach so do i i think of them
exactly like spectre
i think the guys that [ __ ] were
involved in those thank you victor
ting spock yeah t spot i think the guys
that
were actually in and that were behind
the guys that were involved in the newer
james bond movies
are talking about what we're talking
about zach i think they are
and i think it's the international
[ __ ] hot the international ruling
class
and they just see us as slaves really
that's what i think
yeah no [ __ ] yeah but yeah so the
funniest
the funny thing too was that um we've
been watching
we've been re-watching like uh star trek
the original series
we've been watching we're almost at the
end of season three last season
what was the episode because remember
the episode we were watching the other
day and i was like drinking it i was
like you
you missed like the first part of it and
i'm like everybody's like so [ __ ]
cranky on this episode yeah yeah yeah
the cranky episode tila says
tila says yeah okay yeah they shot
exteriors of burnt offerings at the
dismantle as well tila man you know you
know your [ __ ]
go ahead and friend us on facebook yeah
that's like the same house they've used
that i know that [ __ ] you go ahead and
you go ahead and friend us on facebook
burn offerings read the book too if you
haven't it's like by robert marasco it's
really really good
that's what like yeah i love like
haunted house [ __ ]
yeah i don't know if i said something
but my dad had a thing for [ __ ] karen
black he thought that was the sexiest
[ __ ] woman
i'm sorry and he said he liked that
little bit of cross-eyed that she had
he [ __ ] loved that well yeah that's
what i mean though like made her yeah my
dad
she was like kind of weird looking but
like also kind of she was hot she was
hot and [ __ ] what was the house of a
thousand corporate of course
when she was like how old was you about
60 probably she was still [ __ ] hot
i thought she was well that's what i
mean that's what we're saying about the
difference between
being beautiful and being sexy yeah
sometimes it coincides but not always
i get molested by this sexy ass old
woman [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] sexy ass
woman just [ __ ] blessed there's
something about her that's like very
very
yeah i can't take it
she's like that weird cross-eyed yeah
that's weird but it's like
i'm like
[Laughter]
i think the thing about it i don't know
i don't know what it is because like
i kind of like people that are sort of
weird looking
but own it yeah you know what i'm saying
like because anybody yeah we're on
facebook 13 o'clock you can get us
through 13 o'clock
and through that me and jenny are
[ __ ] connected to that yo if you
could find us go ahead go ahead and
friend on there
yeah you know your [ __ ] go ahead and
free you're in the club you're in the
club
you don't have to appear in the way or
anything you know burnt offerings you're
in a club
i feel like that's still really
underrated yeah it's a [ __ ] excellent
[ __ ] movie
that's one of my favorite haunted house
movies from the 70s yes
i mean not in the changeling are like
some of my very favorite
i mean the haunting is my favorite one
in the 60s
and also that's my favorite haunted
house novel ever haunting of hill house
there's a lot of good [ __ ] haunted
houses
i like the evil that is awesome yeah i
like the evil which is a weird haunted
house
with a fake burt reynolds in it dj
maniac says i bet you love steve buscemi
if that's the case i do actually i like
bashami he's cool
because like i said he's like kind of
not ugly exactly but it's like
he's an odd looking guy he's odd looking
but in a
in a sexy kind of way just because he
doesn't care that he's odd looking
like i said it's not so much what you
look like it's how you
project like out to the world so it's
like if you look weird
but you're like confident about it you
own it you're like yeah [ __ ] this is
what i look like and it's like
[ __ ] deal with it there's something
like really really sexy about that
i know that's like strange but it's not
always about looks because the thing
about it is that
when you're really really good looking
like look at some of the mo i don't i
can't think of any examples at the
moment but
you know because i don't know who's like
super popular at the time like
at the moment but i feel like a lot of
like just
attractive people are kind of see me
like you know what i mean like i feel
like a lot of them like kind of look
like one another
i kind of like confuse them for one
another like is this
that dude or that dude they all they
kind of look alike and i can't really
tell them apart
because i feel like they either have a
similar look and that's why they get
chose or they got
similar like plastic surgery like to
look the same or whatever
so i'm always kind of like more
interested in people who
just look really distinctive like
immediately you know who that is
and but they have something else to
offer like you know what i mean they
have like some other kind of
like they're really funny or they're
really smart or something like that
we've talked about this before
where i don't know if this is just a
woman thing or a dude i don't know what
it is but it's like i do feel like
looks are not as important
either when you're a woman when you're
older whatever i feel like personality
goes a long way toward and confidence
goes a long way toward
making you attractive to other people
really no matter what you
look like like if you have like other
things to offer because
i mean let's be honest about the [ __ ]
people's physical
attributes even if you're beautiful when
you're like young and stuff like that
you're gonna get old you're gonna like
look like an old person
we all are um so you better cultivate
like some other [ __ ] because if you're
like coasting on like look how cute i am
yeah that's not gonna last very long i
hate to tell you so
that's kind of where i'm coming from
with that yeah see
she says confidence and a great sense of
humor go a long way they do
indeed and uh yeah i do kind of feel
like that's
the kind of thing um okay so let me
i like willem dafoe too he has a hot
voice he does
actually please tell me you saw
antichrist did it bother you because i
know it bothered a lot of people but it
didn't bother me as much i thought it
was a really good movie but i don't know
i was i wasn't bothered by the
general mutilation i guess a lot of
people were
we watched carpenters vampires today and
loved it the practice see i need to see
that i don't think i've seen
john carpenter's vampires because i just
i heard it wasn't very good you haven't
seen john carpenter's vampires right
uh not that i remember i don't remember
seeing it not that i remember
tell us that it was that we should watch
it they just watched it today
okay exactly carpenter zach says i think
young jack nicholson is kind of hot too
he was actually a good looking dude when
he was younger like if you see him in
like the
what you got oh thank you mango great
show tonight guys
thank you a lot but we'll
holy crap weren't sure we were gonna
make any money tonight
[Laughter]
we went what two hours without [ __ ]
making any money oh i don't know we're
at three and a half hours now
we've been going on brazil yeah i was
actually going to talk about the
paraquat murders but i don't get around
to it
that was actually well it wasn't it's
not like a um that happened in japan
it happened like a couple years after
this one and
i'm not sure if it was a copycat of this
yeah but it was somebody that was going
around poisoning
cans of um it was like this vitamin c
like an energy drink
like in vending machines in tokyo yeah
and they were going around like somehow
like poisoning the cans and like putting
them back in the vending machines and
people were getting them getting sick
with uh paraquat which is like a
herbicide that's what they use over here
to like kill marijuana plants
that's like what the dea uses so there
was like a rash of them like in 1985 and
they never caught that person either
so i'm not really sure if that's there's
not a lot of information about it in
like
english language because the the
wikipedia page is in
japanese yeah and the english one is
just only it's like very very
brief oh um hey badge um just uh you
know i've [ __ ] gotten some videos
from you before i kind of know who you
are
if um if you and your wife ever want to
come to florida man hit hit me up i got
a room here you guys can stay in
if you ever want to come disney or
whatever just give me some warning
i mean we're like how far are we from
disney half an hour about a half hour
yeah we're about half an hour
right but i wouldn't recommend disney i
go to universal
well but there's lots of theme parks
here yeah
i actually i actually really like animal
kingdom yeah
it's a great butcher yeah universal is
good too
yeah so if you ever uh if you ever need
a place man just [ __ ] just make sure
you give us some
warning yeah crash here
we got a spare room yeah i've got a
kitty that'll like jump on you tonight
and he says when you're gonna invite me
i don't really know you yet maniac you
can you're you're a [ __ ] heavy hitter
but yeah
yeah [ __ ] just give us warning
tls says are disney and universal both
open in florida i think they both are
at this point um to a limited extent
yeah
uh alex says if you're in the area you
got to hit up bible land
yeah you got to go to holy land yeah is
that still open
victor's going she wants to stay at
[ __ ] 13 o'clock man
you gotta [ __ ] spend money to come a
[ __ ] 13 o'clock man
no i'm just saying uh you know what i
mean i extend the invitation
[ __ ] on certain cases you know long
time [ __ ] patriots yeah we show you
guys for a long time yeah long time page
you're not going to kill us
i kind of know who you are you know
i'm friends with them on facebook and
stuff you know i mean so
um i can work things out but they're
overseas you know what i mean
[ __ ] badges from england yeah so it
costs a lot of money for them to visit
the united states
like you know they gotta fly over and
then they're gonna stay in a [ __ ]
hotel
thank you victor yeah one night at 13
o'clock manner for five dollars
got it bro you got it tom might even
cook for you yeah
he'll make some indian food yeah or a
pizza yeah
it all just depends on who you are tammy
says well i'll go and have a sleepover
yeah that'd be fun actually well [ __ ]
five to have a sleepover here at this
place and [ __ ]
we're gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna put on a
big camera we're gonna [ __ ] televise
that [ __ ] live
we'll stream it yeah yeah
and pookie will be she won't know
pokemon yeah pookie will be in it
she'd be like who are all these people
yeah why are you guys at my house
yeah but if you come visit me me and jen
you gotta have money too because when
you come here we're gonna buy some [ __ ]
you can't have broke dicks up in the
house you can stay free but we're gonna
buy some [ __ ]
we're gonna we're gonna have [ __ ]
food and all kinds of stuff
i'll send you ass send your ass down to
[ __ ]
universal or disney or the clubs
we do spend a lot of money at the club
yeah which reminds me
starry night's coming oh we're starting
it's starting
they're playing at wolf's pub i think
also this monday
is they're doing another memento mori at
eibar
the halloween it is yeah so we probably
had to go to that
yeah zach you know i know you zack
[ __ ] you can come
you put your gay ass up in the [ __ ]
up in the [ __ ] guest room
i'll hook your ass up with [ __ ] toby
to [ __ ] toby the leather daddy
power bottom i haven't seen toby yeah i
mean we haven't been out
toby would do bad things to you zack i
had to keep him away from you
he'd hurt you you got to watch these old
people yeah he he was the worst
he would go [ __ ] rob halford on your
ass in a [ __ ] heartbeat oh for sure
he's like hand me the whip
shut up in his [ __ ] leather vest and
[ __ ] with his [ __ ]
leather [ __ ] hat on that little
[ __ ] little [ __ ]
cop hat that he wears and [ __ ] [ __ ]
dick's gonna be sucked bro and that
shit's off
you better watch out oh my goodness
dick's gonna be suck
tammy says i'll share pookie's bed yeah
everybody's trying to come over to the
house now you started
yeah all right poopy sleeps in our bed
usually she either sleeps in our bed or
she sleeps on one of the dining room
chairs for whatever reason she's decided
she really likes
just sleeping and yeah in one of the
dining room chairs i go out in the
morning and make coffee at like seven in
the morning and there she is
yeah i don't know she's weird i think
taylor said she's in california
i'm from california what part of
california you in tila
you and your husband probably over in
southern california
i was from [ __ ] long beach long beach
and carson around that area
alfred announced an interview this week
that he swallows
because some comedian accused him of
gargling in an interview with sebastian
which pissed him off damn that's right
sebastian bach was that guy from that
[ __ ] other metal band i think it was
[ __ ]
white lion wasn't it no that was [ __ ]
wait was it was it a white lion or
poison or something no it wasn't poison
one of the [ __ ] was one of the winger no
when it
was one of them [ __ ] homosexual
pretty boy metal bands
that all the girls liked not me
yeah well you know there was a whole
that was a subset of what yeah i didn't
like that kind of mess you're talking
about
because i was in school at that time
when that happened like you had two
contingents
you had like the new wave and punk
chicks which was me
and my friends yeah and then you had the
other girls that liked hair metal
and we did not like those girls if i was
going to [ __ ] with metal it's going to
be straight on leather daddy metal
[ __ ] [ __ ] rob halford man judas
priest
thank you skid row that's right yeah
that's right i couldn't i knew that
dude's name i just
think of what band he was wrong iron
maiden doing some british
british [ __ ] [ __ ] straight boy
metal
[ __ ] i liked i like metallica but it
played out quickly
but then remember all the black metal
like venom
venom and then california had slayer
that was that was good too man [ __ ] i
liked that i don't mind
i actually kind of like slaying them
yeah
venom was kind of like a kind of like
the motorhead
of satanic metal it kind of had a a
heavier groove to it kind of blues
sounded i liked it
i can't say that i'm all that familiar
not really a metal person
gotta say some of it's okay but yeah
tammy says the bed's gonna be crowded
because my cat has to sleep with me
yeah okay pookie will sleep with us
in like shifts like she came up last
night and slept next to my knee for like
three hours
and then she [ __ ] off yeah and then i
found her
she was actually sleeping in the in the
front room like by the window
maniac says slayer was more like thrash
than black metal yeah i guess it was
yeah but it had that satanic
[ __ ] angle to it i liked slayer man
season seasons in the abyss was really
good
[ __ ] um [ __ ] what was that other one
that had
[ __ ] man i'm trying to remember that
other [ __ ] one in the head [ __ ]
had war ensemble in it
oh [ __ ] that was a war ensemble what are
you looking at me for i don't know man
you don't know that [ __ ]
it's been a long time since i've heard
all day all i know about slayers
south of heaven and sword yeah
yeah so you're done with the case yeah
well can we shut it down now
yeah do your do your plugs like you said
you were going to do that you got to do
a plug look
if you guys were looking for more
patrons you can join us at patreon
patreon.com 13 o'clock
if you're already a patreon remember to
go vote on the halloween shows yeah
make sure to like and subscribe another
thing is is that jenny's got a [ __ ] ton
of books you guys can [ __ ] look at
the books that she's got going on and
[ __ ]
um [ __ ] where's that [ __ ] called i'm
dropped
what's that [ __ ] what's that i knew this
was gonna happen she [ __ ] wrote
she wrote a [ __ ] ton of books and got
more [ __ ] books coming
we're gonna get her some help [ __ ]
sophie's gonna join the team to be a
research assistant
to help up rece to help speed up
research for the show
and which will free her up to do some
more stuff for the book so we can
get book production banged up because
that last trilogy is selling really well
well i'm gonna do another i'm looking at
i i think i'm gonna do another faceless
villain but for the 2000s and i think
i'm gonna make it four books
four books and i think i'm gonna add
disappearances and also
solved cases from the cases that were in
the old books
that were solved in the 2000s right i
think i'm going to add this it's a
highly rated [ __ ] true
that's my next project everybody seems
to like it
selling real well we don't really have
anything for [ __ ] paranormal coming
up
uh unseen hands still selling pretty
sales are steady on that
yeah but the market is calling jenny to
go more towards that
crime well and i'm kind of more
interested she's more into that
to be honest yeah paranormal it's just
it's a smaller
subset there's not as many customers the
the market doesn't ask for it at the
same rate
crime does people can't get enough
they can't get enough of that crime i
can't get enough of true crime yeah i
watch that all the time like for fun he
doesn't let me because he's like man
this shit's so depressing
jackson jenny i could help you with your
books too i'm down here
down here if i'm down there if i'm down
here tom can't read
yeah i'm drunk man i'm seeing like
trouble
um okay [ __ ] mega says
he's on our way for halloween all of us
if that's true man if i could just pop
in
you can be on the show you can be on the
show i gotta i got my costume i got the
last part of my costume in the mail
today i'm so excited i thought it wasn't
coming and i thought i was gonna have to
like
you can bring you and your wife
compromise we got a small private it
showed up
we got a small semi-private um airport
just a few miles from here called
sanford airport
it's like sanford slash orlando internet
sanford slash
orlando international airport that is
never busy
and it's never [ __ ] crowded you can
fly it's like the secret area it's like
the secret airport
and if you [ __ ] try to get in there
uh it's actually cheaper sometimes and
you're in and out of there a lot faster
and it's
super super close super super close
that's one
that's the one the orange man uses when
he comes here we're not we're not saying
that yeah
you're not saying that she's mad about
it well i'm just mad about his existence
in general isn't that something
[Laughter]
why does he exist i like trump go ahead
why not lightroom i don't get it
i don't get it i just think he's
hilarious though he's a terrible baby
i think he's hilarious he's funny he's a
terrible human being next halloween
y'all should dress as regular non-goth
people
see you know everybody says that and
it's like i don't know if i could do
that
though although i will ha i will say
that one year
was this last no this wasn't last year
maybe the year before
a memento mori we had like the halloween
whatever and everybody dressed up our
friend shawna
who's like this she's from
uh where is she from [ __ ]
shawna's from [ __ ] boston brockton
brockton brockton massachusetts outside
boston
and she's like a skater she's like a
punk skater chick she's got the [ __ ]
shaved head the dreads and everything
like that and
she came as like uh
yeah i don't even want it it's like it's
like a week like
midwestern like housewife yeah
they can't get a good mind's eye view of
her
all right she's mixed all right
and she came on like a 70s
kind of like afro bell bottoms
she just looked [ __ ] cool it looked
it looked like a real
person it didn't look like a costume
well that's what like when she first
came in like a real black chick to me it
just
like it was it was weird because she had
like well she had like a cardigan
yeah first and she was carrying it like
that and she looked like a seven
and she walked in like she had like this
weird kind of like seventies and i was
like you're
just [ __ ] that and then like it took
me a second and then like a minute i
recognized her and then i left my
[ __ ]
yeah she looked like if you guys ever
seen an old sitcom called good
times she looked like a cast of somebody
off the castle
like jj's mom or jj's sister
that's what she look like yeah kind of
and she this is a goth punk rock kind of
skater
chick you know what i mean
her her dad was black her mom was from
where
[ __ ] somewhere in europe i can't
remember i think she was from
holland i don't know i think she was
they met some
they got together they met in some
islands somewhere remember they were
like in
was in haiti or something or jamaica or
something i think it's what they said
they were
and when we've seen her when we see her
she just looks like a [ __ ] punk rock
chick or something you know with all
these [ __ ] dreads they turned around
and all of a sudden just something like
straight at a good time and she's
carrying like this white purse
purse pearls yeah like [ __ ] horned
rim glasses and [ __ ]
and it took me a second i was like huh
and then we just laughed and like
[ __ ] laughs because if you know her
it's like way funnier you know her it's
[ __ ] funny because she's just
and she had like i think she had like
nurses shoes on yeah something like that
i don't know if i took a picture did i
take a picture of her
i don't remember yeah oh my god that
made me laugh so much but yeah she did
dress like a normal person
and we did like make a joke about how
tom should like dress up as a golfer or
some kind of [ __ ] which is probably
funny but i don't know it's
i don't know it's alex and i thought she
was from revere alex must know her i
think she might be from her no she was
from brockton yeah she didn't bro
she lived in brockton maybe she was from
revere
i guess alex knows who who she is i
don't know
how do you know that bro that's some
weird [ __ ] are you stalking us
i thought she said brockton leslie asked
me have i ever
danced to bella lugosi's dead oh many
many times talking about many times that
was the
national anthem it is here in the united
states you kind of have to dance to it
that or [ __ ] fascination street
by the cure that was the other guy i
will usually sit that one out because i
as much as i love the cure i'm not a fan
of that song
i have to say that's probably my least
favorite cure song
that was the national anthem though i
know but i'm just saying that right here
but i will dance to the bell of the
ghost
although i would prefer that they would
play because bella goes he's dead yeah
[ __ ] man that is such a long song it's
like [ __ ] nine minutes
and mango says the whole chat room is
coming i can't have all you [ __ ] up
in my house
drinking up all my booze and scaring my
cats and [ __ ]
i gotta know who you are one at a time
and you can't be some broke dick dog
coming
sucking up all my [ __ ] but i tell you
this [ __ ] badger
do you come here bro you come here i'm
gonna take your british ass to the
[ __ ] range we're gonna shoot some
machine guns
i got special range for that a special
ring yeah i got some [ __ ] that you
[ __ ] freak out you're like you own
that oh you gotta do on that
i got some [ __ ] you're gonna see if you
come here alex said from the halloween
you're buying ammo though well yeah
yeah you ain't shooting up my [ __ ] zach
says i don't drink time just get some
good pot ready
yeah okay we can arrange that probably
[Laughter]
are you are you ready yeah i don't
[ __ ] smoking that weed though i
grew weed i don't like i'm not a fan
like i i understand how other people
don't like it but it doesn't affect me
in the way that it affects them other
people it affects me and like it really
makes you slow negative way make you
slow no it makes me
um makes you like worried
and like i said i don't need that i get
enough [ __ ] social anxiety i don't
need more on top of it i need something
to like [ __ ] chill me out
weed's only interesting when you're like
in your 20s which well it does chill
some people out which
i wish it did to me but it doesn't it it
has the opposite effect so
that's why i don't do it um but yeah so
you ready to wrap it up we're almost at
four hours she's looking like pam grier
um not well pam
had a killer ass [ __ ] figure she's
pretty
if you go back and you go back and
[ __ ] look at pam back in the 70s
man for her ethnic
group that's what she wanted to look
like that's the way that was like the
ultimate black woman
[ __ ] now um our friend
our friend doesn't really look didn't
really look like that you just we did a
show you could see
you can see a long time ago yeah long
time ago she was on one of our hollywood
specials are
one of hers but yeah she's been here uh
now that
it's a different type you can you can
tell she has some kind of germanic or
teutonic features
to her you know you can tell she's mixed
um pam just looked black to me you know
pretty much what did you say yeah louie
says is we
legal in florida uh i don't know
i think medical weed is nobody cares
yeah i don't know but nobody cares about
that i don't i don't think anybody cares
yeah especially nowadays
well civilization is [ __ ] kind of
fragile and falling apart
it's legal to [ __ ] burn up cop cars
now nobody gives a [ __ ] about anything
and stuff
nobody likes caps yeah but like well
there yeah i think we have
there's a car that there's a there's a
house that is like um
on the trail where i'm where i walk all
the time
i'm pretty sure they're growing like a
[ __ ] ton of weed in the back yeah you
can smell it
every now and then you walk by there and
you can like smell it and bikers
yeah yeah it's bikers they have like a
whole compound man yeah you like
like oh yeah so we they're they're
testing out the supply today i guess
it smells like it's very very punchy
like that that sticky
weed resin yeah things about
that's just here's the [ __ ] thing man
why did they give a [ __ ] about that that
was growing here naturally just for
forever
that's just something that that's the
big question of this yeah that's it
that made [ __ ] reaper madness yeah
that is an artificial worry
yeah i mean uh i i would think that
alcohol would be
a bigger risk than that well alcohol
makes people act more bad than we do
yeah
i think so we just kind of makes you
look kind of sleepy and hungry it's just
a bunch of outdated rules
made by people that are long dead that
this shit's got to pass
a lot of stuff has to go you know and
i would consider myself you know i have
a military background i'm a [ __ ]
law and order type guy i do believe that
there should be law and order because if
there's no law in order that means i'm
in charge and you [ __ ] you don't want
me in charge
you do not want me in charge not me and
my buddies because we're going to do
whatever we [ __ ] want to do
you know what i mean and i have a might
makes right type mentality
growing up in the third world in [ __ ]
brazil and [ __ ] mississippi and [ __ ]
and
kind of you have to have somebody
refereeing [ __ ]
if not dudes even worse than me will try
to take over
victor said i want to do the whole
florida thing disney nasa eat someone's
face off
[Laughter]
yeah the old [ __ ] yeah him i forgot
about him
i forgot about him that naked sexy
[ __ ] eating another man's face
also you might need to wrestle an
alligator get a wrestle
that's right i mean yeah if you want the
whole experience
[Laughter]
all right how drunk are we we're
probably this time
it's like what is it exported in a nine
hole yeah it's like i'm probably gonna
have another drink and fall asleep
watch some horror movies hopefully you
guys had a good time and hopefully we
talked enough about the case to like
justify what i titled this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm sure someone will complain yeah but
i'll delete it
so uh yeah so anyway hopefully you guys
had a good time
hanging out with us on saturday night
and we will see you guys
tomorrow you did your plugs right yeah
i've got a
[ __ ] zack said that pam grier was hot
and he's gay
he said well she's just like universally
hot i feel like
well here's the thing i kind of [ __ ]
up when i was talking about pam greer
because the alcohol i was saying you
know like back in the 70s she was hot
she was hot in the [ __ ] 90s look at
her escape and escaped from
she she was hot then too that was what
96
97 something like so she she stayed in
good shape for a long time i don't know
what she looks like now but
she was [ __ ] hot leslie said there's
a good movie called fade to black from
1980 they actually just added that not
too long ago on shutter so it's actually
on my
movie review list matter of fact now
that you mention it
um yeah so you kind of did plugs but
then you kind of [ __ ] it up
[Laughter]
it's all entertainment so if you would
like to
financially support the show it'd be
much appreciated go to the patreon page
patreon.com 13 o'clock podcast or
you got our blog 13
o'clockpodcast.wordpresswordpress.com
and there's a link in the sidebar to a
paypal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation
any little bit helps out the show we use
it to buy new equipment we just like i
said bought a new camera so we could
film pookie
and do some other things might also use
that for a webcam we'll
experiment and see if it works any
better but yeah so
uh we will see you guys tomorrow like i
said on the matinee live we're gonna
start doing like halloween themed movies
like newer ones
so we're gonna start doing that tomorrow
we're gonna have a whole halloween week
full of [ __ ] and i'm really like excited
about it
leading up to our next halloween show
which will be next saturday night so
spend halloween
night with us next week it'll probably
be
true crime related uh because that seems
like it's
in the that seems like it's in the in
the running yeah
of the patreon so we'll see how it goes
but uh yeah so we'll talk to you guys
again tomorrow
bye